tonight you're gonna see something that
you've never seen on a bodybuilding show
before and you may never see again
Dorian Nasser pastel Ben fato
Ben Aziza munzo where you going with
this I start yelling I need doctors I
need doctors now
then Aziza died in our arms I mean
that's how bad it was
doesn't sound like you're supportive of
that everyone feels as the years went by
the drugs got more were you everyone
connected to them up or no I think I
could take over to support you can't
teach this you can't teach somebody how
to do this you either got it or you
don't have it why are you throwing how
can I guilty I said Joe I got these
ideas so bent fire you go to the
elevator I push the button the elevator
door opens up there's one person in
there Arnold why do some people not like
you should make some things they thought
they were making money and we were
pocketing it while two Thurs went to
Weaver's don't [ __ ] I'm gonna bring
Robbie Robinson to your gym then you're
gonna put my posters up and you're gonna
sell me tickets there's the name of the
contest call me coordinator champion
what are you talking about it go rocky -
Night of Champions - right they're super
bold it's a net oh god you just sent me
the wrong camel come on Mohammed please
come out please come out and talk to me
Mon Ami you still have the passion for
this game put me on that stage they're
in a debate over I'll call Bernie the
crazy go run a search it's gold in the
surface you're no falling apart of the
IFBB let's do it we're gonna put on a
show
[Music]
did you ever think you would you
paralyzed when we got fat AV value
taemin given values contagious this
world entrepreneurs we can evaluate a
haters run homie look what I become
[Music]
so today we have another one of these
bodybuilding interviews except today's
slightly different I'm not sitting with
a mr. Olympia contender or bodybuilder I
am sitting with somebody who promoted
more bodybuilding competitions than
anybody else in the history of
bodybuilding and someone who promoted
more mr. Olympius 18 times than anybody
else and he took over the committee of
Pro League I think for bodybuilding in
1979 Pro division which used to be
Arnold and then you took it over from
1979 to all four so we got a complete
different type of a dialog to to to say
the least so with that being said my
guest today
Wayne DeMille your Wayne thanks for
coming out thank you so so when you're
watching all these interviews with these
bodybuilding interviews on this
entrepreneurial channel called vitami
what are you thinking when you're seeing
some of these interviews they're living
in the past they're living in the past
let's get to the press guy who cares
about you know what went on in 1998 you
know at that Olympia when Chad came in
with the plasma expanders let's see you
know here we are trying to keep the guys
alive to protect them from themselves
from 92 Ben Aziza died in our arms
basically we were in Holland at the way
the last show with it tour and he was
pushing it and we kept saying you know
Momo you know pull back a little bit
pull back a little bit no no no I got to
win them all because they were all vying
for wheter contracts at that time the
show ends and I'm told by one of the
other competitors he was throwing up in
the back
well extreme vomiting diuretic overdose
Momo you've been taking diuretics let's
go to the hospital contest is over you
won let's go to the hospital just check
it out let's be safe no I'm good I'm
good I'm good we get on the bus we did
the contest in The Hague and we were all
staying in middle harness middle harness
is a little sailing town where Juliet
Bergman former Miss Olympia lived with
her husband Jim Lynn's felled and they
were Co promoters of the event so they
put us in a hotel down there and they
had a restaurant there and we're gonna
have a party at the restaurant
I knew the area well because my
girlfriend at the time was a Dutch girl
French Indonesian Dutch girl and when
she got pregnant with my son she had met
Juliet it wanted a contest when she was
with me and Juliet said why stay where
your mother lives because you know
America was another my medical insurance
and she said I'll have the baby in
Holland the won't cost you a dime as
we're about Bernie talking about all
that at every mm-hmm every night so I
new middle Hornets I knew the hotel and
everything this Annette so we go back
after the contest they had a party
I'm almost having trouble standing
walking his legs or like cement we call
the doctor doctor comes and he checks
Momo
vital signs heart pulse blood pressure
normal we call just something wrong look
he can't even walk
we think it's diuretic overdosed isn't
it he goes he's over the age of 21 and
his vital signs are normal
I cannot force him to come in okay two
hours later again he's getting worse we
call the doctor again again Momo don't
want to go not food poisoning he's
telling us
okay won't go in about three o'clock we
all go to bed you know so I go down the
street they were in a hotel I go down
the street and about 5:00 a.m.
there's knocking on the door I get out
of bed I'm there with Tracey you know
and Morse Ellis was like three months
old and it was a bodybuilder lq girlie
he goes you better come almost bad so I
just throw on clothes if we run down the
street we get there he's on the ground
he had vomited already said call
paramedics called the ambulance dissin
end portal katrell was there bodybuilder
on the tour Porter was a fireman I
supported with CPR so I'm on one side
I'm holding his left hand looking for
pulse
Bart bed way one of the judges is
holding his head after we cleared it's
his throat Porter's doing CPR when
I felt the pulse disappeared I looked at
art and I go he was gone they came they
put the electric things on him boom boom
boom flatline boom boom boom flatline
they tried a three-four times
strapped them up took them we're all
sitting there in a daze we knew
something like this would happen because
they kept pushing it pushing it but now
it's it's real and then the phone call
comes and the photo person says who's in
charge there were points of me so I get
the phone and they go please come down
your friend has passed away you got to
do body identification and sign the
documents in this scenario so we go
everybody comes with me we're all in
shock we all go to the hospital just
like five minutes away in the next town
and I go in to see the doctor that came
twice that night and the head of the
hospital didn't have people dying in
that little town and the doctor was
crying it was a young fellow he was
crying and goes I don't know how this
happened on this happened and I said to
the time how did it happen he goes
obviously whatever they were taking your
vital signs stayed normal till the
moment of cardiac arrest that the body
compensated so as he had no circulation
or whatever in his legs and then his
arms it was compensating until the heart
went so okay
you know it is what it is but then all
the things I never thought I'd have to
do you know yeah we had to go down they
said you have to go down he's in the
morgue everybody wanted to come down
here I got male bodybuilders I got
Juliet I got all the female athletes
that were there two came to see the show
and you go down into the morgue it's
cold that thing opens up and there's a
slab and there he is laying on the slab
no shirt on which is perfect upper body
no shoes on and just the tag on his toe
you know
somebody athletes couldn't handle it
they started crying his training partner
from France went grabbing the body Momo
come back come back you know we had a my
friend dart was there we had appealed
him out of there get him out of there
Ida signed the documents and there were
other complications Momo you know
bodybuilders old ladies men
okay well mo was married he was engaged
to another girl but he was there with a
16 year old and she was there his poor
little girl was devastated cute girl
cute little blonde French girl holding
on to his flip-flops crying her eyes out
I mean imagine what it's like for 16 she
was 16 17 in there she was young and you
know so we get her out of there I'm
saying you know I feel bad I'm going
after this poor girl's go to the home
and then they go where you're going what
you know I signed the papers you're
gonna make arrangements to get the body
out of here we don't do that
you got to buy a casket and then you you
know you don't think about these things
I'm a bodybuilding promoter so here it
was Sunday morning it's now by 7:00 a.m.
they helped me out whether they
understood the situation how to buy a
casket how to read the hearse how to put
get space on the plane cargo just ship
him back on the same flight as hard to
Lyon but now I had to have our hearse
pick him up there I had to have and set
up for the body to be kept before they
buried him and I had to call a family
you know you leave that it's like what
am i involved in this for what am i
doing what year is this 1992 what are
the body builders were there in the room
when they candidate cried Holmes or any
major names are know who was on that
tour ninety-two Steve bris blah was his
training partner there and he then
Brisbane opened up to me and said you
know I had big problems Thursday night
but we kept it quiet sunny schmidt was
on that tour
how cute girly
on that tour Terry pastel was on that
tour just off the top of my head so you
know we get rid of all of that I come
home it was the last show with a tour
and I said to Ben wieder I said you know
we got to do diuretic test and we got to
get back into testing you know this is
not my job to go to hospitals with
people well you know this and that they
didn't really want to get into testing
we get to the owner classic the next big
show in 1993 and at the competitors
meeting I said look we all know what
happened to Momo I all we all know that
you guys are gonna push the envelope but
if somebody pushes it tell me I mean
don't look at me as daddy that I'm gonna
yell at you we want to save lives we
can't have this again everybody yeses me
yeses me yes a little contest dissonant
and contest is over and I go to the
banquet at the Arnold that they had back
then they used to hold it in the
basement of vets auditorium and it was
very loud and everything and my son by
now was eight nine months old something
like that and there's a mellow kid but
you know it was too noisy let's go back
you know in Columbus at the Doubletree
you come in on the ground floor you go
up six levels because they're all
parking levels and then there's the
lobby and then there's another Bank
elevator so we just come off welcome to
off the elevator is Juliette in
dreamland felt and Julie echoes you'd
better go to my keys room like matarazzo
I said why it looks like the same thing
as Momo I look at art art looks at me
saying oh my goodness no no don't say
that
I said Tracey you know can you take care
of it she goes don't worry I'll go to
the room do what you got to do so we go
up there knock on the door it's Mikey's
mother I knew my mom and dad when I'm so
glad you're here you listen now every
room was a suite so you come into the
living room and he goes mom okay mama
I sit on the bed and I put my hand on
his thigh and it was cement
and so go Mikey you're okay you're okay
you think it okay come on Mikey get out
of bed knock me off the bed huh I said
make a multi mineral solution and I said
call an ambulance
no I'm not going to the hospital mighty
you went too far we got a savior so
paramedics come and they do the same
thing high pulse blood pressure they go
to normal yeah well we went through this
six months ago we did in October here it
is March 5 months ago Mike he goes no I
don't want to go to the hospital the guy
goes the paramedics go we can't take him
in he's over 21
I said look a guy died and with dealing
with seconds here take him in this is
his mother wants him to go this is his
girlfriend wants him to go he was dating
at the time sandy Rydell who was a
female body go we can't legally do it
and I look at art and I go take the keys
and the guy goes why now our bed way
with big burly guy pins the guy against
the wall he rips the keys off I said
either you work with us or get out of
the way
we're commandeering the ambulance and he
goes I'll do this I'll do it it's good
they were afraid because or it was big
and I was gonna get violent I wasn't
gonna let Mikey die we take him down we
get him to the hospital in there I put
his mom and his girlfriend in the
ambulance me and ran the four blocks to
the hospital once we got there we got
there at they're pulling in and they're
taking him out I said we got he needs
doctor right away we're dealing goodbye
now he couldn't raise his arms you just
lived through this we get into the
emergency room and I go I start yelling
I need doctors I need doctors now right
now right now I need dr. bull security
comes luckily he was Columbus and they
were all retired guys and they weren't
armed and they say all right and art
goes you're coming aerosol at you you
know and five doctors come I said you
got her over dose of diuretics he's
doing this I said we need IVs put in
them we need slow drip moulting
no solution we need slow drip of things
just muscle relaxers to relax them dis
Annette so they put IVs in his legs in
his hands and in arms okay slow drip
everything they got his pulse going it
starts going down 60 59 58 we're
watching it with the gun we're gonna
lose him and it gets down to about 28
it's in the 20s and then it started
coming back he was out his eyes are
closed started coming back and then it
got to 60 again and we just looked at
all each other me and five doctors and
we just take a sigh of relief and I sit
down and they go to me Wow good thing
you knew what to do doctor where do you
practice I go I'm not a doctor I'm a
bodybuilding promoter and we just went
through this and I said we're not out of
the woods yet I said when he comes to we
got to find out how much growth hormone
he spent on because if he doesn't have
food the growth hormones are these in
stores eating muscle and your heart is a
muscle and you could still go with the
cardiac arrest
so one doctor said God got wise with me
goes oh you're not a doctor with it what
do you know then I said know what take a
blood test
check his metabolic rate go ahead check
his metabolic rate so they take a sample
of blood and then the guy sheepishly
comes back about five minutes later
can't measure it it's off the chart I
said by now Mikey woke up and I said we
saved you from one thing Mikey tell me
how much GH you talk you could whisper
it in my ear if you want I for at least
8 or 10 I use but they won't need see
they don't need so it burns all the fat
and so I said get all the candy bars and
cupcakes from the nurse's station get
that Mike ended up staying in the
hospital another four or five days
before he could go home before he
normalized
we had incidents would flex twice on a
tour with diuretics and one time when it
happened happened in Spain we took him
to the hospital they gave him some
saline solution and everything
normalized them they were going to send
him home I said I don't feel secure he's
putting them on a plane from Madrid to
lay 1012 hours what if something happens
over the ocean no he'll stay with us so
we go to Germany and we're giving him
fluids and then he starts passing out I
was there with Kevin Love Roni
and he starts passing out we get him
back to the hotel and I call an
ambulance again said flex we got taken
and of course you don't want to go but
we he's got to go we take him in there I
get the guys to the theater you know
we're gonna start judging but you know
we'll put it back a half an hour
everybody's worried he was in bad shape
and I go back and the doctor said to me
what is this man doing chemically I know
bodybuilders take drugs but he's goes
his left kidney is basically shut down
his right kidney is weak I said flex you
gotta give me your bag of goodies we got
to know what you're on so we can do all
this so we found out Justin that he was
in the hospital close to a week you know
I remember how to called Madeline came
over Mary - Madeline time he had another
incident at a time on the tour you know
we lost ondrea's Muenster combination of
things right after the san francisco
grand prix one another time at the owner
class that you can find this on youtube
all delet overdid diuretics goes into
the rear double bicep any lock thread
then we took him off like a board but by
that time we had portable IV units back
stage along with doctors to start the IV
before the ambulance got there I mean
that's how bad it was
there was one Olympia where we had
portable IV units I had four guys on IVs
between rounds 1 & 2 so I said to the
weeders look we got a diuretic testes we
got to protect them from themselves
these guys like any athlete is going to
do anything they can to win we all got
to do whatever our profession is we want
to win we're gonna take that edge ok so
he gives in so we're gonna diuretic test
and we get to that meeting in New York
and 98 and that's when she woke up and
said you know what about these plasma
expanders I don't even know what plasma
expanders whirring and it's all coming
out and yeah I mean did I call Chad and
probably threaten him score what are you
doing though I mean we're all in this
together we're all like a family when we
were on a tour if anybody said anything
to anybody
foreigner we'd all go after that person
you know they may fight like brothers
but anybody go after your brother you
know the whole family goes there that's
the way it was yeah we all want the guys
yeah I wanted all the guys to look as
good as they can but healthy and now
you're doing something you know I think
I threatened or I'm gonna test all your
guys for plasma threat there was no test
for that I was just shooting my mouth
doctor I was so upset and it's like what
are we doing
you know bodybuilding supposed to be you
know the ultimate male the extreme you
know the look like this you know we all
we look at the pictures when with
teenage boys or I want to be built like
this all the girls are going to love me
in this a net a lot of times these guys
are the most unhealthy on stage they and
and their life is in the balance and it
shouldn't be that it wasn't like that
before even though they did things I
wrestled in college and when you how to
make weight you know they would tell you
saw that then yeah stop drinking water
for a day and a half or something some
stupid thing like that okay yeah and the
water would come out and you'd make
weight and then you drink water and
you're heavier what do they do with
boxing or what do you think that the way
in the day before you could put on 10
pounds 20 pounds of you know how to do
whatever you're doing back in the old
days what did they eat I mean when I
started running Night of Champions and
all those shows when the guys would come
to New York they'd stay at my house this
is before I had children they dive their
tuner and water and they cut down their
water and they just haven't protein and
they're cutting back in this and they
looked good you're gonna tell me that
the guys today look better than Robbie
Robinson and Danny padilha in the 78 79
Night of Champions or Albert Beckles and
Chris Dickerson in the early 80s most
people would prefer those physiques
because the smaller waist and everything
and they were healthy let me ask you
this
what's your point with starting with
these stories because oh you know you're
saying Shawn yeah I mean I said let's
not live in the past and listen let's
talk about what's going on today and you
went right into it
you sounded like a politician like from
yesterday's the baby when you started
with that but what does your point with
starting with these stories what what is
your outcome because it's a drug test
okay so your outcome is they should
addition drug this so are you going back
to the time where you drug tested Sean
Ray and he came out positive and he
didn't
dianna class is that kind of where
you're going with this well what we do
in IFBB physique America when Rafael's
and toka called me up after Jimmy split
and the IFBB the parent IFBB had no
American affiliate when he asked me to
come back I said the only way I'm coming
back there has to be drug testing and he
said we drug testing the water I said
well every one of my contests will go
under a random water drug test and will
drug test could be a number of athletes
according to how many is in there so
nobody knows if they're gonna be tested
so if there's you know say 24 athletes
in the contest because we're building
we're small well test to male to female
baseball what are they tests you've got
26 guys on the team and they test one or
two guys out of the 26 that's all they
test you know of course there's 162
games and we have maybe 20 contests but
at least we're drug testing and people
know we're drug testing and if you get
caught according to the IFBB rules just
suspended for four years
who chooses who gets drug tested it's
done by random how do you do that what's
the approach we may take an independent
person and put all the numbers down and
say these are gonna be the male numbers
these are gonna be the female numbers
pick two of each
is it done privately or publicly in
front of the athletes oh okay you do
this in front of yes
oh that's very firm okay so that's not
it's not like because you know sometimes
politically because you picked on young
I want to pick on this guy okay I get it
so that's first to do that it's when you
do that way that's very fair yeah okay
and and you know we send it to a lab or
what a lab or they do the water test or
whatever the heck the thing is I mean
there's a lot of things on our honor
tests that we don't need to do we
haven't had any problems of diuretic
overdose anybody cramping on stage that
they had to come off we also had these
guys we never you know oxygen thing for
them on the side when they needed oxygen
so you didn't like that era it doesn't
sound like you're supportive of that era
because as the years went by the drugs
got more and I kept saying you gotta
remember my relationship with the
weeders and this is another thing Shawn
didn't understand I know he made the
comment because people call me and said
Wieters will pay a new money I said no I
was paying them I was what would what if
after I was appointed to the position
then eventually I started a company
IFBB Pro division Inc my company I pay
taxes wasn't a federation the IFBB
recognized me to run pro bodybuilding it
was my company so yeah if I acted like a
dictator at times like she once said yes
I did because it was my company and you
cannot do what you want you're an
independent contractor you can join my
company of your own free will or you
could join any other probe bodybuilding
organization out there it was your
choice because I was given away more
prize money than anybody else I was
taking care of the athletes better than
everybody else by flying them in and
taking care of their hotels food
allowance but you had to adhere to the
rules you had to do press conferences
like anything boxing okay we just saw a
championship fight those guys had to do
press conferences they had to do all
sorts of publicity because the promoters
are putting up the money and you are the
stores and you got to help generate the
money
nobody cares about Bob Arum always
paying money to see Bob Arum no one else
yeah but they're paying to see the
boxers and you got to create that hike
where you watching them and they're
bad-mouthing each other and they get you
excited that I Mouse put down that what
do I need on sounder bucks yeah would
you consider yourself a promoter would
you say you're promoting a nation you're
promoting okay so but by the way you
sound like you you had a you know you
know you sound like some of my other
guests that I'm happier like mob
affiliation did you have any mob
connections back in the days or no
because to be able to do that you gotta
have a strong personality to handle
other little things like Dana White give
you an example they know why it's a
promoter Dana's not scared of a lot of
people because Dana Gant Dana's coming
from the streets where he's a tough guy
to handle the guys that are UFC guys you
got to be a tough guy to be a Don King
you can't be scared of people I know
people that we're people what I'm saying
to you is you kind of come across as
that kind of a DNA how did you become
who you are who you were when you start
a promoter like who was Wayne before he
became the guy that's you know fitness
I've always been when I play
baseball team softball teams I was
always the captain a coach that is sit
at the player coach we all push some
buttons or no I was always in in a
leadership position I'm a typical Leo
born in August okay God um well you have
everyone connected to them up or no no
but they used to come to the shows
Oh shows us guess almost every show any
big names or know who I on say okay
anybody that's been a guest on my show
no he didn't okay got it
no but his his father's son yes yeah he
was big into bodybuilding a lot of them
yeah and a lot of my friends of mine
just passed away by the way who jr. no
no oh no no I'm not talking about that
guy that was 103 oh you're not about him
no no God he junior oh okay I got it
okay but a lot of the guys you know in
Brooklyn back then in the late 70s early
it was to it yeah they were into
training they'd come to the shows in
this and act I don't have no problem
yeah would you consider yourself a tough
guy or no no I reason above guy but I
have to be tough I have to be tough one
I have to be tough no I get again going
back to it I said you know what you get
my face I'll be right back in yours so
what I'm saying is how did you become
that who would you or who who pushed you
around where you had to be tough like
how did you become the way you are I
always was you grew up in the streets of
New York are you a reward reward you
grow up huh
I grew up in New York you grew up in New
York yeah and in high school you were
the leader in high school were you the
guy that sports the cool guy the ladies
guy who were you I went to an all-boys
school I went to Brooklyn Tech for smart
guy stuff to be a ladies guy yeah a
lady's guy okay so what do you do after
high school
the high school I went to college what
are you trying to be at this point or
each I was got a degree in engineering
okay and then I got a job at a college
with AT&T but I had taken an elective in
college in political science in
constitutional law and it fascinated me
so I decided to go back to college
because AT&T would pay for it and I was
saying ah maybe I'll become a lawyer I
went to take political science and I
took communications but communications
meaning debating
Asian volumen tation to be an attorney
or a politician I got those degrees but
I went to a bodybuilding show what here
1973 I wanted to go there was two shows
held it was bodybuilding world they
always do stupid things
dan Laurie used to be part of the IFBB
he even said that he started the IFBB as
son has incorporation papers that he
started the IFBB in 1948 he incorporated
and we just as he started in 1946 who
knows they were at odds so Dan had the
WB B G the weeders had the IFBB they put
the shows on the same day to try and
kill each other dan goes and gets as a
special guest Steve Reeves now I had
seen Steve Reeves when I was 10 11 years
old and those Hercules movies I want to
go buy a ticket to see it but now I'm
working I had money I could buy a ticket
because when I was young as a teenager
mr. America AAU mr. America was always
held in New York Pennsylvania was 13 14
my mother said where you going you're
not going to York Pennsylvania on a bus
by yourself at 13 you know I never went
I got out of body believed for a while I
was into boxing I box for sure so were
you bodybuilding I trained I never
competed
okay got it you know when I found out
about the drugs I wouldn't take drugs
why not harmed your body it was it was
defeating the purpose after that contest
in 73 we're on a won the Olympia because
I couldn't see Steve Reeves so I went to
the IFBB show I said I'll see this fella
Ahnold because I was reading the magpie
it was at the bodybuilding 66-67 when I
want to first came on the scene in the
Navi universe but then I got into boxing
and I stopped bodybuilding I was just
total boxing and then I got back into it
late 72 again a friend of mine at a
magazine I said oh I remember this guy
on or with the funny last name he's the
greatest bodybuilder in the world he's
mr. Olympia Tyson and I look at the
thing was late 72 said the contest was
gonna be 73 I looked at the other thing
there's Steve Reed but I couldn't go to
series so I bought a ticket to Brooklyn
Academy to see Arnold and honor wins
that night and they give him the check
and he takes the microphone from the
podium
and back then everything had a wire
there went wild and he's pacing on the
stage looking at the check I'm saying is
this guy doing you know and then he just
stops any goals I train or yeah I train
all year last year they give me a
thousand dollars just here 7:15 he
throws the mic on the floor and walks
off I go wow what a wild sport this is
entertaining why isn't this place sold
out so I joined the gym mid-city gym
that promoted the show and I meet the
guy that was the promoter Tom minutes
hello and he was the IFBB vice president
at a time and so I joined a gym and I
said oh Tom you know I went to the
contest Saturday Wow Arnold was a
character yeah that's on will being on I
said well why didn't you have any big
sponsors and he goes to me well when big
companies are ready to sponsor
bodybuilding they'll come to me because
I run the Olympia at a big show and I go
with Tom nobody comes to give you money
you got to go out and get it no no
you're too aggressive you're young
you'll learn stay back you wait and
people come to you and I walked out of
that room thinking if this is the guy
that's in charge of the Olympia and the
vice-president and this is his way of
thinking I think I could take over the
sport I mean that was the thought in my
head in that moment in that moment huh
so I became friends with Tom and I said
you know anything you need because I was
to living home with my parents in
Richmond Hill Queens not by JFK Airport
you know so he goes no why you could be
my gopher anybody comes in instead of me
having to pay for a taxi you could go
pick him up and bring him in I said okay
so that's what I would do so I got to
know everybody the only guy that didn't
come in that I had to pick up was Arnold
Arnold the man that a limo or whatever I
got to meet Arnold later on in 73 he
came back to New York to do something
he's trained it came in at lunch time
and he was in the locker next to me said
hey I go hi I saw you in the thing oh
yes fun we just told what's your name my
name is Wayne and we shook hands and
this and that and we trained a little
bit together dissing at just two guys
you know I wasn't a groupie you know and
I think he enjoyed that you know cuz
other guys well just another guy and you
know we struck that up in 74 I help
Tommy rain in Eastern America in the
spring and the mr. America the mr.
Olympia in
and I helped him with everything this
and that for free I bought my tickets
but I did a lot of work and I was going
to go around I'd go around a contest no
matter what the Federation was buy
tickets and then offer my help backstage
just to see what they were doing wrong
not what they were doing right because
they would I'm thinking like why aren't
these shows run better what's wrong here
in January is 75 Tom goes to me I'm
gonna make you the Metropolitan director
of the eye of the AABA which was the
American affiliate to the IFBB because
they hadn't affiliated with the AAU NPC
yet you can run the eastern America
contest this year Wow Tom thanks I go
into the gym all the guys that I'd see
it train at lunchtime
it said guys guys Tom's gonna let me run
the eastern America this year what's so
funny
goes if you don't run that show then we
got a show in the spring and then the
show in the fall will go to the AAU and
he'll have no no amateurs for the fall
show so now you're gonna lose the money
instead of him and he's still gonna get
us in the fall I said I'm not gonna lose
money I think what do you mean I'm they
said I'm gonna get a sponsor to cover my
expenses they looked at me what's a
sponsor I said it's a company that gives
you money in exchange for exposure
you're looking at me now I'm 25 years
old I said I'm gonna figure out my
expensive so one of the guys that
trained there was an assistant principal
of a school around the corner and he
just come to me cause when you want to
use law school it's not that big but he
says you know there was only like 30
people in the audience at the Eastern
America last year so we've got 200 seats
it's plenty big enough I said okay let
me go see it we do it he says I'll get
it to you for free well you got to do is
throw 50 bucks to the custodian to come
in on a Saturday I said okay make sure
the lighting was good because I
understood lighting a little bit or no
yeah and so I figured out my budget
trophies printing whatever you know put
posters up and my budget was $600 so a
friend of mine worked at JFK part-time
in a hotel reservation company with a
husband and wife reservation
so if you came off a plane and you
didn't know where to stay that night you
go to them they'd book in a hotel and
they get the Commission and I said to
them look you give me $600 everybody
that comes in from the show will book a
hotel room through you with an amateur
show to add a book but then they'll know
about your company because of all the
publicity anything beyond that is gravy
so we're gonna break even here because
you'll make enough money and then it's
necklace like all the guys coming in
from California you know the wieder pub
no photographers eNOS and I may have you
yet met the wheelers or not yet yeah I
had met the weeders I met I met them in
at the show in 74 I just said hello to
them
but not a real sit-down conversation
nothing yet they don't really know who
you are and what your ask notions are
okay no I got my thing covered I had met
Jean Mohs a Jim Jose at the time was the
editor of muscle building for the genus
passed away - and I said to him I'm
gonna run the eastern America I called
him up at the wieder building and I said
can you give me an end he said well I
could give you a half a column and I'll
run it for two months okay so I had an
ad in muscle builder for the contest I
didn't I know the concept yet it going
around to other gyms and everything but
I knew mid-city gym had to have about
500 members so I got on every one of
them you get your tickets yet for the
Eastern America you get your ticket guy
who's like wait here here's my $5 give
me the stupid ticket leave me alone let
me train then I would go all hours of
the day because I was at lunchtime but
guys that trained at night with
different guys on him he was only open
on Saturday wasn't open on Sundays and
stuff I sold the 200 tickets in advance
reserved in the front with chairs where
the norm was 650 folding chairs behind
them were $5 and then you know standing
room was $5 so I made over $1,000 I
remember how we working for AT&T making
about a hundred and forty dollars a week
and Here I am making twelve hundred
fifteen hundred dollars I was I knew I
was gonna make money so I even bought a
TV set for the winner you know I figured
I don't know what to do you know making
all this money I'll buy something
besides all the trophies so I go in
Monday morning everybody's telling me
how great I am Saturday night you know
there's a fun time seeing all the guys
from the gym and you know seeing the
guys all these guys come in businessmen
of suits now they're coming in you know
the way they hang out on a weekend and
okay so I go in on Monday morning or
train at lunchtime Tom goes get in my
office I said what's up Tom you have a
good time
ever the worst contest to have a sword
this was Betty he reams me out I leave
there and I'm in my mind I'm in a daze
I'm saying oh it's like going to gym and
it was Pat me on the back and isn't it I
said why is Tom yelling at me saying it
was the worst contest ever and the guy
that was the principal you know who just
came in to Train and that educated guy
goes well you know you understand what
happened I said no because he's jealous
you did what he can't do
he's lost money in that show and you've
made you know you're an ayat you said
you made you know over $1,000 close to
1,500 and he's jealous and he knows
you're better and he you know like you
know more I said but I'm running it unto
him and learning it for his Federation
and they go welcome to the business
world a real business world a cutthroat
business world when you're very
successful some people don't like you
they're jealous of you and this Annette
okay by the time we got to the fall show
you know he didn't want me involved with
it that much
and this Annette but what he did was he
had pictures up on the wall that my
girlfriend at the time took she
eventually became my first wife and he
used some of these pictures on the
poster I know what laws are so I said to
him I'm still training at the gym
because I paid every month he wanted my
money I said you know Tom you're using
Karen's pictures well they're on my wall
they're mine now their hardest stamped
you could put them on the wall but
you're using for advertising purposes
now you got to remember back then
prejudging wasn't open to the public
I don't know why there was another thing
I'm saying you're throwing money away
but that's the way they thought back
then and I said and only select people
could be it
judging along with the judges yeah so I
said you know can me and Karen come and
take pictures in this Annette well I'll
think about it now he had a partner
we're gonna go to the thing and I had
met Joe Weider by the fall of 75 what
happened in the summer 75 I have been
write letters to Joe Weider I didn't
really know if there was a difference
between Joe and Ben you know he's got oh
you don't know yet yeah I just decide
I'm just gonna go so I get an airline
ticket I get on a plane I rent the car I
look on the map Woodland Hills I go to
urban street to 1:100
urban street so I just go one way or the
other till I meet that number Wow here's
the Wiener building I was impressed this
beautiful big building this is body
building Wow
so I walk in and they had these big
paintings on each wall but oh 10 12 foot
Larry Scott on old Franco all the guys
these big paintings that you walk in and
I go I'd like to see Joe is yet this
point making money Joe Joe of course
yeah what kind of money is he making at
this point is it real money or not yet
oh it's real money it's real money yeah
okay well you know the story about
Arnold how he talks about in the book
Total Recall he says the first time I
went out there to visit Joe it was a
little shack it wasn't like a big
headquarters there so this is and this
is at the point is the major building
threw out a major 1975 or 76 75 75
Woodland Hills or Woodland Hills yep I
said well talk to gene mosey
he knows me tell him Wayne from New York
was here so gene comes down hey Wayne
you know this I said I want to see Joe I
wanted I got these ideas he goes okay
come on up
so he introduces me to analyse Joe
secretary she goes you got no
appointment I said no I came from New
York I want to see Joe well sit here was
like 10 o'clock in the morning i sat
there till 6 o'clock every time she'd
look out you're still here I said I'm
still here
so finally she goes he'll see you what
are you doing here what are you can I go
phew I said Joe I said I ran in the
eastern America contest last year Tom
got all upset and this Annette I said I
want to run pro shows what you got is
mr. Olympia and you know those are the
stars and without the stars it's boring
I said so I think by
Ballu should be like golf and tennis
where there's Grand Prix things and you
get points for the shows and this and
I've had all these ideas they looks at
me and goes I'll never work but it's not
me you got to talk you gotta talk to my
brother your brother man he's the head
of the IFB can I just run the magazine's
I don't do nothing yes was he telling
the truth
well he did run the magazine's but he
was Ben's big brother he would always
tell Ben what to do so he is just
pawning you to Ben right now but the
final decision is gonna be still well
it's good to be part of the IFBB it's
gonna be Ben but you know they would
always play good-cop bad-cop got it
you know so I'm saying I came out here
for not honest in it of course four
months later I see Joe's editorial we've
got to take pro bodybuilding and make it
this dissonance right all right so I
start writing you know you got to
remember this is before email and before
any of a fax machines you had to write
letters I write letters to Bend wieder
I'd like to come up and see you and this
and that I get know where other people
that I was helping will body build I
said write a letter to this guy now we
get to the 75 show in New York mr.
Olympia was being held in South Africa
pumping iron Pretoria I'm there and the
night before everybody's in town because
I'm still picking up the guy cuz now the
guys don't even go to Tom they could
just call me up Wayne can you pick me up
my flights coming in at this time so I
bring them in and I see Joe with Tom's
gym and he goes off come get me
I don't want to take a cab Joe with a
little cheap pick me up and take me
because it was being held at the old
felt for important Madison Square Garden
I said okay so I pick up Joe now I had
said to Tom you know we may be getting
prejudging right well I gotta talk to my
partner Pete yeah I don't think there's
a problem okay so we get to the felt
forum now they had New York City cops
there my dad
former president at a PBA Patrolmen's
Benevolent Association in New York at
that time in 75 he was the vice
president he was known so we get there
and I said you know to go into the back
door and we come with Joe and and they
go what's your name I said
miss Karen Clark this is Joe Weider I'm
Windham Ilya says he goes well Joe
Weider is on here I don't see Karen
Clark hey so Joe goes while she's with
me taking pictures for me so the guy
goes okay so the guy goes to me you know
Sam DeMille yeah that's it that's my dad
I said he's your vice president at rppa
so we are talking in this Annette
and the next thing Joe comes what the
heck is going on and they're they're
throwing Karen out so we mean that
thrown Karen out camera comes out she
goes Tom's partner Pete doesn't want me
in there I said but he's using your
pictures totally your pictures on the
poster you didn't pay you a dime that's
technically against the law
I go to joke you go in there and you
tell Tom if he don't let us into the
judging I'm gonna sue him Tom comes out
all shaky you want to sue me you're
gonna sue me
clean out your locker get out of
mid-city Jim you're out of here and this
and I said fine I leave Joe's going why
you're going where you're going I said I
don't need this you're coming back
tonight right no I'm not you think I'm
gonna give him any more money and buy a
ticket I'll buy it for you anything be
more of two tickets and he's cheap cheap
anybody yeah I wasn't way in the back in
the cheap seats but he took Karen up
front to take pictures for me because he
liked her pictures I went back to my
locker
Mitch City Gym I took the thing they go
Wayne what you doing here I was on him
out of here I told him the guys in the
gym you're quitting I said yep I'm gonna
deal with this no more you know I said
he can't handle it as it Tom's a nice
guy he's laid-back you can't be nice as
a promoter you gotta push push push push
every day that's how my brain goes and I
said you know I want to do bigger things
yeah I was in the back and you know I
went out with Joey during the guys that
night not Tom Tom wasn't with them I'm
with all the guys and everything and I
continued to write I said you got to
talk to your brother where's your
brother Ben was there and then Ben took
off you know Ben didn't hang out with
the bodybuilders Joe did and I said you
got to talk to you about you I'll keep
on him keep on him so I write and write
and write and finally a call and I get a
secretary Pamela Kagan on the line and I
said hi I've been writing she goes
you're the guy from New York with all
these letters and get all these people
writing I said yes I want to come up
there and speak to him
got these ideas and Joe said I should
speak to me they go okay the world
champions now whole year went by we're
talking now to fall of 76 and I'm still
going around an amateur shows learning
World Championships in Congress was
gonna be held in Montreal he said she
said to me I'll put you down for a time
with president leader I was like seeing
the Pope I remember the time I had a
Thursday afternoon 210 to 220 so I
checked into the hotel you're gonna be
in and I get there early and there's all
these people lined up I'm thinking like
wow how do you do it like a doctor door
pick a number what do you so I see this
lady there and she has a pad and
everything I said are you miss Kagan she
goes yeah she goes uh you're the guy
from New York Wayne I could tell by the
way you speak I said yeah
she goes to ten you're behind this guy
right in this Annette okay so my time
comes I go into this room Ben had this
big opulent suite and you go in and
there's a chair there just like a little
folding chair and there was three steps
up and Ben was in this big armchair like
the king I thought I felt like I was
seeing the Pope and she goes mr. wieder
this is Wayne d'emilia from New York
who's been writing us for the past year
so he looks a mini goes well okay you
got your time what do you want to do I
said I want to run Pro shows I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna do that pop-up op
op-op he looks at me do you compete no
sir do you own a gym no sir I work for
AT&T do you even work out I said Mr
wieder you're skinnier than me and
you're a president to this thing if I
was in the gym competing all day taking
drugs how could I be a promoter and he
left and he goes typical Ben Ben was a
politician I learned a lot from bang we
fight all the time as years went on we
fight constantly one of the reasons why
I left I just had enough but I learned a
lot from him I give him a lot of credit
on a lot of things he goes well you know
Joe got the idea for a pro committee and
only those people on the pro committee
could run contests and we're going to
start the Pro Committee tonight so if
the chairman of the Pro Committee wants
to put you on it you could be on it I
said okay
who's the chairman greatest champion on
a Schwarzenegger I said okay okay I said
well I met Arnold in the gym three years
ago and I said I'm good friends with
George Butler and I'm an independent
unpaid consultant on pumping iron and
whenever they have screenings in New
York I go to it and half the time
Arnold's there and we're goofing around
so you're Arnold getting along at this
oh yeah it's a relationship yeah okay so
he goes well if he wants to put you on a
committee it's fine with me I said well
thank you shake his hand leave say
goodbye to mrs. Kay again there's an act
no lie I go to the elevator I push the
button the elevator door opens up
there's one person in there Arnold I
think to myself in that one split second
this is meant to be I go on oh you
starting a pro committee tonight I want
to be on it then okay come to my room
seven o'clock is my room number okay so
I go there the original committee Jim
Lauren was there I had met Jim Norman at
a contest the year before they were
supposed to be another aaba contest in
1975 and the promoter had four guest
posers he's gonna have Arnold Franco
Louie and Chuck Cipes 1975 all big names
but he forgot to do one thing sell
tickets and get amateur athletes in the
show the only athletes were the guys
that came with me from mid-city gym and
he sold two rows of tickets but he
double sold the first row and the guys
were fighting and arnold goes i have a
friend here in columbus that could help
out and he calls jim Norman that's how I
met Jim Warren got 1975 Jim always hit
it off saying can you believe this guy
so the whole plate there's 4,000 seats
in here and he sells the first row twice
that's the only people he had so Jim
Lorimer was on that committee and it was
John Balak was on that committee from
Ironman and this Annette but I'm looking
at the guys I'm saying I already got a
tentative date on a venue in New York
for the spring of 78 I figured I'm gonna
do a spring show again going back a
little bit that Monday after the first
show I ran in 75 when Tom Murray me out
I saw you know all the guys in the gym
talkin so I see another guy dare that
I'd see every day and I go on
what'd you think
contest because I didn't I couldn't make
it Mike I got a flat and I never got
there I said really he goes yeah I said
you got your tickets he goes yeah he's a
dwarf reserve I said here's $13 give me
the tickets that gave him a refund it
goes I see you here every day he said
who did your ad I said I did you know
copy thing said it's terrible
it sucks I said really it's just like
the ads in a magazine he says well the
ads in the muscle magazine don't know
what to do he gives me his card he says
after we trained today come on up to my
office I'm the vice president of on-air
design for NBC so I go up there and we
talked and I said I tell you what let's
be partners I got all these ideas
staging and everything but I can't do
all this hard work I'm not an artist you
do the ads I come up with crazy ideas
for staging because look at the stages
black curtain and a thing no it's gotta
be staging we got to do this we got to
do that and you do that and I take care
of the money I sell the tickets isn't it
we split 50-50 it goes fine we shake you
know about a contract I said to him I'm
gonna go up there and get the rights it
laugh at me okay
whatever Charlie with a little older
than me Charlie stole a life and he'd go
okay you know go ahead do your thing so
I come back to the room after saying I'm
gonna see Arnold that night I say yeah
I'm gonna be on the committee only
people on the committee can run it I'll
let you know who's on the committee
after I go there tonight and I looked
around I'm saying maybe Arnold and Jim
Lorimar gonna do it because they're
gonna run the Olympia here they just ran
the Olympia in 76 and they're running it
again but nobody else in that room is
gonna run a show and I got the date set
so when I got back and everything wrote
a letter to Ben wieder and I said how do
I go about locking in my show I'm gonna
do a show in the spring of 70 yeah I
need 18 I figured I needed a year and a
half I couldn't do it that quick from
November to May I never run a big show
that I wanted to do prize money in this
net remember the prize money in the 1977
mr. Olympia was only 12 five or $15,000
total and I was going to give away ten
and there wasn't many sponsors for big
shows
I figured I'm gonna sell every seat I
will sell every seat I don't care about
1650 or a 5000 no no now I'm doing a pro
show the judging was five dollars go now
I'm going to first show that the judging
was open to the public
how many showed up oh I had over a
thousand people at five bucks yeah okay
so he made for this is a 1978 September
in May of 78 and the finals I sold for
10 12 and 15 I was sold out before I
went in and then you know you talked to
the theater manager and they'll do
standing room half and half because it's
all cash I did well we made money we
made about mmm seven eight thousand
profit on that first show which was a
lot back then you know thirty five
hundred four thousand dollars a piece me
and Joe are you still working at AT&T or
network oh yeah oh you're still working
at okay we're full-time job yeah how
long were you at AT&T until 1985 okay so
you did all this stuff while you're
still working full-time yeah yeah I know
you are you married still or no you're
not married married in 77 so what time
is show in 78 I was married to Karen at
the time and wanting the show and
working for AT&T I just bought a house
this Annette and then the guys will come
stay in my house I bought a big house
for the bodybuilders to stay in my house
now the interesting story about that 78
show I go around earlier in 77 late in
77 Dan Laurie ran a contest and he
advertises on old versus Sergio
everybody wanted to see that again
and they were saying he put down invited
to compete but it was in very small
print everybody sort of pictures arnold
and sergio everybody bought tickets
sergio showed up I wasn't going to show
up because he was under the IFBB and
they said you're not allowed to go into
a non-sanctioned event sound familiar
you know so he didn't show all the gyms
that sold tickets for Dan Lori all the
fans were yelling at the gym owner and
everything you know I want my money back
I went to biodiverse
sérgio he wasn't there so here I come in
January 78 and I got a poster to the
biggest star in the sport at that time
it was Robby Bobby came on the scene the
Black Prince the afro the vest all
shredded up you know that's coming out
dissonant to any padilha boy echo had
joined the IFBB two years before from
being in other things I got them all on
this poster beautiful poster with
overlays and mezzo tinsel Charlie did it
of course it was better you know when we
did an ad like the first poster Joe
vehicles who did to say call me up
oh that's ad it's better than any ad in
here you're making me look bad I said my
partner Charlie I wanna talk to him I
want to hire him later on that year when
we had the universe in 78 in Acapulco he
goes to Charlie you know I want to hire
you
Charlie goes well you gotta pay me more
than NBC you know well what are they
paying you this in 1978 Charlie was a
vice president because I'm getting paid
80 grand plus all the things they jungle
rot Joe was freaking out by anybody like
that you know Charlie was Charlie would
run the affiliates Joe a millionaire
yeah at that time yeah but Joe is cheap
okay yeah so I go to the gym in Bath
Beach gym in Bensonhurst Brooklyn in
1978 everybody was John Travolta in the
gym the black slicked back hair the
white t-shirt with their pack of
cigarettes under the arm just right out
of the movie I come in I'm going to go
to that gym because that's the big hot
gym and I go in there and I go hi you're
the owner goes yeah who are you I said
hi my name is Wayne and I'm gonna be
running a showing man I'd like you to
put up my poster and sell tickets for me
he looks at the thing that's Robbie
Robinson I said yeah it's friend of mine
a heck of you I said well you know I'm
just I'm a promoter I'm but I just sold
tickets for Dan Laurie we all know Dan
laureate look is his name is on every
one of the plates in my gym you know
because Dan Lori made barbells and he
said he was gonna have a long
and Sergio and Arnold don't show up and
everybody wanted money back and now you
come in here you're gonna be in Robbie
Robinson and Danny put Diller and boy or
Cole get out of here he goes to me I
said no they're gonna come and this guy
comes here and this guy comes here
camera goes I think it's gonna be a hit
I go I'll tell you what I tell you what
I look at him like this I take out my
wallet I said here
it's my driver's license it's got my
address on it goes yeah I said see just
phone number on here
Ticketmaster didn't exist yet this how
far back we're going ticket no no
Ticketmaster you the last three weeks at
the box office or else by mail order and
if you wanted information that was the
phone number in my car
okay and that's that's my home phone
number
give me that calendar he looked at me I
said give me a talent off the wall now
he's backing up a look like I'm getting
aggressive may 6th Saturday May 6 the
contest Monday here the first we go back
this day in April this day in April 8
p.m. Robbie Robinson I'm gonna bring
Robbie Robinson to your gym three weeks
approximately three weeks before the
show but when I do then you're gonna put
my posters up and you're gonna sell me
tickets copy down Maya and if I don't do
it or your Guido friends here they
couldn't come and take me out
copy it down they go you're a cocky guy
you know that I said copy it down so
they copied down my address and
everything
I call them Karen goes you sure I said
come on just what did we do in the
summer we spent two weeks at Robbie's
house so I call up Robbie is it Robbie
you know nobody want to sell these
tickets and you know I got you Center on
the thing
could you come to my house like a month
before he had no problem I said good
I saw set up your airline ticket I'll
fly in his wife at the time he Lane I
said I'll fly in Elaine - so you and
Elaine long you want Elaine here you
know I always got to double check that
with bodybuilders no no yeah I mean
Elena cominis and
so he comes a week before us and I know
I got so I said so I set up like five
gyms to do that we're going on that
Monday night eight o'clock
I said let's leave I'm in Westbury Long
Island we gotta take the Belt Parkway
all the way down and they're good hour
plus
let's leave early so we go we can't park
within six blocks at a gym okay now I
had been called I called Johnny Barbera
the owner I said remember I'm coming
Monday night I called him the Thursday
before he goes you better he said I got
signs up you better or we're coming out
there I said no problem you know so we
park a couple of blocks away and we walk
in me and Robby up walking together
talking our wives are behind us talking
this and that and we're walking get to
the street where the gym is the gym is
three-quarters away down the street and
it's like a banner or so and there's
like 30 40 guys outside any oh man we're
all them people you know Robby with that
Devo well any people yet I said that's
the gym they're there for you not to my
aunt man you all crazy people from
Brooklyn man will you create it right a
lien people hold on to you you're gonna
have make sure I get saved
you just do what I tell you to do we're
gonna sell tickets and they're gonna
love you I said because you came to them
they're gonna love you says we're
getting close to somebody goes there he
is now you know when a bunch of guys
talking to you that low Rumble silence I
was like Moses and Robbie was my scepter
I'm not parting the Red Sea they just
opened up and they're staring and we go
into the gym it was a storefront and the
gym was in the basement and everybody
goes from stand along the thing and we
walk in and his johnny is father his
brothers his uncles I go Johnny Bob
arrow Robbie Robinson and they're there
with their motto the father takes a
hefty trash bag takes everything off the
shelf for you Robbie you came to my gym
could we take a picture you know
and in this Annette Robbie cuz ya sure
dis Annette I said now remember that
Karen's got tickets she's gonna count
them out with you we got a bunch of
tickets we're gonna go downstairs is
everybody in down at Jimmy said it's so
packed down there you cambrie I said
we're gonna go down there
and you're going to announce could they
all had a little speaker system Robbie's
gonna be competing in this show and we
got tickets on sale that was the deal he
goes you got it so we go downstairs and
it was walk walk you couldn't even train
look rather cousin man what do I do
I said you're gonna stand on the bench
you're gonna take off your shirt and
you're gonna hit some shots you okay
just as long as I get out of here alive
and then I'm gonna take you home and
feed you okay you know you feed a
bodybuilder habit he's enjoying great
shape
you know and they're going crazy because
back then no internet
this was the pages in the magazine
coming to life and you got to remember
1978 magazine was black and white
here's Robbie in the flesh in color
right in front of them on a bench posing
and you're looking at him saying wow
this is real look at this and I when he
finished his pose and I said in
two-and-a-half weeks on May 6th Robbie
Robinson is going to be competing in New
York at the Town Hall and Johnny's gonna
have tickets get your tickets Robbie
we're gonna be there for you we left
them a hundred tickets for the finals
and about 40 tickets for the judging on
a Monday night Tuesday afternoon he
called me and he said I need more
tickets so we had five gyms like that
and Robbie was the one that did the
publicity for me the first year they
were chanting his name in the theater
yeah he was the best bodybuilding on
stage but he was also the favorite and
they were chanting away and this Annette
I had Ricki Wayne who was the editor
he was the emcee I said Ricky I want
this showmanship he says okay I said I
want you when it talks what color you
want and he goes to me peach I said fine
you know I looked around I found our
peach tuxedo put him in Pete
I said no podium I want you walking
around like a stand up coming goes I
love it cause Ricky was into that too we
did all of that you know standing room
only the aisles were filled with people
everybody's dissing it now the original
name of the contest was the American
professional bodybuilding championships
the theme was a Night of Champions
because we were going like boxing
the thriller in Manila every every
boxing match had a theme two months
after the contest the kid calls
I get a phone call because I was the
ticket number I want to buy tickets for
Knight of the champions - I said no did
name it a contest with the guy goes why
aren't you there
it's called Night of Champions and I'm
thinking back and I say yeah it was
you're right Night of Champions he had
tickets to go on sale because by then I
was saying I needed a bigger theater I
was negotiating with the bigger Beacon
Theater had three thousand seats instead
of 1500 I remember call him Charlie that
day Charlie Charlie there's the name of
the contest gonna be called the night of
champion what are you talking about it
goes the kid named it then naming it
like Rocky - Night of Champions - like
this - Night of Champions - we're gonna
put a woman numbers like the super balls
it's a net okay it goes okay you know
that's what you want yeah go ahead
and that's how it became Night of
Champions and we did things that show
that we did for 26 years we did things
unique it got so unique if we want to
use that word the weeders wouldn't come
no more you're running a circus in E - I
decide no we're gonna do Carlos
Rodriguez with a body builder who lived
in Arizona but he was really from New
Jersey and Carlos said not a champion
it's gonna be my last show I'm gonna
retire I said tell you what after you
pose you know you could do it from the
stage and then I go let me a call us you
live in Tucson Arizona you got a horse
yeah I'm gonna rent the horse you come
out on a horse get off the horse I said
we'll put a little thing at it you tie
the horse up - for the stage for your
pose and then you put your posing
routine in front of your horse you go to
this page you retire and then when you
get on the horse we'll play that old
cowboy song from that TV show of I don't
know is Gene Autry or whatever happy
trails
and you'd ride off into the sunset and
will dim the lights he goes okay the
Sunday before the show I'm home on a
Sunday afternoon I'm looking you know
tickets are going I'm almost sold out
already and when I got bad news I said
what up Carlos I hurt my back I can't
move I can't come I got
horse that can't come he hangs up I'm
depressed I'm walking around the house
depressed I call up Charlie Charlie goes
it was a dumb idea anyway what the heck
is in your head I said nah I got to do
something I said I had my I was set on
the horse you know it's something that's
never been done and we got to do things
you got to be creative you got to be
entertaining the bodybuilders all do the
same things we gotta be creative well
whatever that go ahead whatever you want
to do I'm looking at the list of
competitors hmm and one name catches me
I wonder I call up the place I was gonna
rent the horse right cuz I couldn't
cancel it on Sunday they were closed I
go guys the gutter was gonna ride the
horse he hurt his back he can't do it
now this was movie animal rentals they
do it for films in New Jersey somewhere
I said do you happen to have a camel
neck oh yeah George I said that's the
camels name yeah I said great can I rent
the camel he goes yeah I said okay I
went to camp is it you're gonna like the
horse with $800 the camels only four not
many people weren't camels I said fine
he said the only thing you know the
camel comes in a little bigger truck
becoming a 45-foot tractor-trailer so
you got to get the police the port and
off all of that stuff back there on the
back end the 76th and Amsterdam so they
could get in the back door to Beacon
Theatre I said no problem you know call
my dad he called the precinct we got a
pardon all I say I'm not gonna tell
nobody nobody will believe me anyway
I'm not even gonna tell him account
Mohammad Macao he who's from Egypt
daddy's gonna be on a camel till that
night because I don't want him pulling
out so I casually mentioned it that
morning to someone and they go to
Mohammad I'll have it I think Wayne said
he's got a camel coming you're gonna
come out on a camel tonight he goes
where's he gonna get a camel from in
Manhattan you can't get a camel so we do
the judging and everything guys go
disappear I have the camel come at 6:00
p.m. police are there Yeah right the
cops are going you were really wearing a
camel for a bodybuilding show I said
yeah
sure enough six o'clock here comes this
tractor-trailer right and out comes no I
said you got the camel and the guy goes
yeah George is in there George's very
mellow that's enough so they bring
George out so here's six o'clock on a
Saturday night in May on Amsterdam in 76
and out comes this camel and I go oh god
you just sent me the wrong camel take
what what do you mean it's got one huh
does they need two humps and the guy
rides in between the humps he goes first
off do you know how rare are two hump
camel is and I said I have no idea he
goes secondly we got the hump basket he
sits in the basket I said oh and then as
he's standing there on the thing I said
you know when I was a kid I see camels
in the zoo he's kind of big oh yeah
there's a big camel I said how are we
going to get him in the door it's only
eight foot high he said we'll tell
George to get on his knees and he'll
call in so George crawls in and we put
them behind the back curtain you have
the front curtain the stage you know the
curtain goes up it says Night of
Champions the platform whatever stage
and behind the back hurt and there was
about ten foot to the wall so we put
George back there and he just sits down
and he's chewing on his cotton y'all
nice guy petting them a nice little
animal it was big and they put the
basket on him the guys start coming back
one of the guys looks oh my god he's
really got a camel so they go tell my
McHale we Wayne's got a camel with
backstage no he doesn't so the guys all
come down it's about 6:30 and they're
looking
there's the camel I said come on you're
from Egypt he goes what do you think we
live in we drive cars on the street we
don't drive camels yeah but for this you
go to the door hello I said you know I
said you're a great bodybuilder but
you're always overlooked this will put
you on the cover of every magazine in
the world and this will set us apart
from everything I said come on he said
okay I said now you're getting a basket
and the camel stand up and there's a net
so macao he sits in a bad cow he's only
five foot three he sits in the basket
but he doesn't hold on and when George
goes to stand up he puts one leg out
this way my Hammond went out the back
that way rolled on his head and goes I
ain't doing it
and he runs upstairs like a jilted lover
goes in one of the dressing rooms six
flights up closed the door and says I'm
not coming out I gotta go up there come
on the guys were laughing because I'm
come on Mohammed please come out he's
come on talk to me maja me come on give
me another chance give give me and the
thing another chance
I'm begging I'm begging and one of my
backstage guys goes goes you got another
problem I said what's that
the Union wants to kill you I can why
the camel just relieve themselves
I said whoa so I go down and I see them
and they want to kill me I'll give you
an extra overtime I don't I said let me
go out the front so the people are
starting to come in and the front
curtains are closed and I see the judges
I remember like I see Jim Mannion it now
nobody knew I had a camel and Jim Mannie
goes to me you know we got to do
something about their diet
I could smell their gas from out here of
course it's the urine from the camels so
they got they got to get buckets and
mops in this Annette I said Mohammed get
in the camel he says I can't run a camel
I said to the guy that came with the
camel I said you look like a camel guy
here's a beard and usin a day I don't
know I said you take the camel out you
make them sit down Mohammed's got a hold
on okay so we agree to do it
Mohammed was I pick competitor number
three that night so the curtain closes
you know after competitor number two and
the emcee goes tonight you're gonna see
something that you've never seen on a
bodybuilding show before and you may
never see again
the magic of Egypt Mohammed Macao and we
play some kind of majestic music -
Chariots of Fire but we played some
other majestic music the curtain goes up
and out of the corner over there
all of a sudden the guy completing out
and the people are cheering and then
they see the camel this gigantic camel
Mohammed on one side and doing a
one-bite I got a picture in my phone too
to show you one on bicep like this and
there was silence for about two seconds
and then they go nuts cheering and he
takes the camel around the platform in
the front and Mohammed's waving to the
crowd the camels getting a standing
ovation
goes and the camel sits down well
Hammett jumps out of the hump seat
whatever you think you call it the guy
goes to me what do I do I go kneel down
majestically
he nails down on one knee like this
holding the camel's head to his and
Mohammed gets on the platform and then
they start that Chariots of Fire music
you know very majestic he poses to team
now he's supposed to name get back in
the pump seat and ride around and go off
he looks at me when he finishes posing
Mohammad and he takes off the other way
he get back on that thing again so the
guy goes like this
ankle the Campbell gets up camel gets a
standing ovation okay Monday morning I
get a phone call from Montreal Canada
van wieder what are you doing
you're running a circus go to Ringling
Brothers go to that circus this is a
bodybuilding show you don't have animals
on stage I've had calls from all over
the place I said these pictures are
gonna be everywhere Ben we just did
something no one's ever done don't you
understand
you know it's entertainment you know
people went let's say they they can't
believe what they saw they're glad they
took pictures listen you're crazy you're
crazy go run a circus go to the circus
you're no pole no part of the IFBB go to
this event wait to see everything sure
enough it ended up on every magazine
around the world and even though people
down he goes to me
yes you got publicity yes the crazy fans
in New York liked it because I had a
taped you know and I sent them the tape
I said listen to the fans on you do you
have that tape till today yeah I sent it
to Wayne galosh and he's want to do a
whole big thing I like DVDs of the
history and Night of Champions with me
doing a voice so interested in that oh
he's doing but you know they never came
to Night of Champions again now I've had
a bull steer on stage or theme that year
was more beef than a cattle ranch okay
so Charlie calls what kind of theme is
that I said well I said you know I
talked to the animal rental place all
the time they got a bull steer I'm gonna
get a bull steer on stage because you
know how big they are
I said yeah they told me it's a little
over 2,000 pounds so we I said built me
a Corral and the hay and everything I
said and the bull he goes but what if he
goes crazy
oh I said no he comes with his thing I
said the bull steer his name is Richard
camel was George the bull steer was
Richard
I said the old lady comes is this master
and she's gonna sit on sighs sage as
long as Richard could see her you could
do anything before the show we put him
in the corral because when the thing
opened up and we had some of the guys
that weren't competing including Sean in
cowboy hats and everything with the bull
steer but before the show I'm in the
back I'm in there with the bull steer
I'm packing things like this is horns
and he was long as she was there I could
do anything I wanted to him you know the
show starts and Lonnie Tepper was the
emcee from Iron Man and he goes every
time I am see this show I never know
what's going to happen it was almost
like on cue the bull steer turns around
this is tail and poos on the stage on
stage on stage in his Corral people can
see it oh yeah the bull but bodybuilding
has to be entertaining was a lesson it
was like that last time I ran Night of
Champions or the Olympia bodybuilding
hasn't been entertaining since I left
they don't do nothing things like the
bodybuilding hasn't been entertaining
since you left
it's boring now let me ask you this why
do some people not like you because I
was successful or I was domineering
you know I'm putting money and ideas and
everything to build a sport you know
when I took over the Olympia prize money
was 50,000 you know we won't even get
into sanctioned fees and when I left
prize money was four hundred and ten
thousand and a Cadillac Escalade would
you leave 2003 was the last Olympia I
ran I had over 5500 paid people and over
6500 in the place with comps at Mandalay
Bay now during the Orleans Arena which
is not Mandalay Bay and people loved
Mandalay Bay cause everything was in the
same facility see it's only the athletes
that don't like me because you know I
made them go to the banquet
I said a VIP ticket holder I wouldn't be
I wouldn't why would the athletes not
like you though they told them they had
to do certain things or outside fine I
want to show you video hang on hang on
because I know your stories I've got a
pace myself because your your your I ask
you one question you can go for two
hours so
got a base my time you can't go down yet
no it's all good I don't mind I'm the
one that would drink a Red Bull before
it comes natural wait till we get you a
monster so so let me pull this up so
Paul I got the videos here okay well I'm
gonna I'm up play two of them okay and I
want to see your reaction obviously see
what you're gonna say here and then I
want to play Shawn's video and then I
know I'm gonna get a reaction from you
so here's you you'll know exactly when
this is watch this one here this is
[Music]
I would do something that nobody does in
this sport I was the head of pro
bodybuilding okay I was the promoter in
Olympia yeah and I would do do it I
would do the press conference and and
the press conference was not staged like
now okay where they have thing I would
let anybody ask me anything and I would
answer it because I had nothing to hide
one time or buddy Shawn goes why aren't
we getting more money cuz the athletes
could ask to I could be a target anybody
could ask if you want to ask me a
question
Jemaine you gonna ask answer questions
you know did David Peck our answer
questions when he was running the
Olympic Germans running everything now
there the reveal sinto could do that
nobody I went out there we had 1500
people at the press conference
I made the guy they didn't like it I
made them dress in a suit they're not
dressed in suits now at the press
conference they I wanted them to look
professional you know you take NBA
players they go on a plane they gotta be
trust you're representing your league
you're representing your profession you
you're a professional look it you
already want you know you're gonna go up
there on sweat suits and everything no
you go dressed once a year you buy a
suit and you go dressed and a lot of
fans saying wow they guys look so good
and you know the guys would get into
colorful thing you could look at some
rose outfits call a fool while it was
different and fans loved it
like I said 1500 people at the press
conference let me pay this other one
here's
yeah they do we did it for free less
than seven thousand people came in
worldwide actually no mr. one you can
check with the Wiener company today that
was for free this year depending on what
kind of modem you have is how much you
pay we'll see how many people log on
there so it's not a million dollars or
twenty five million pneumatics of the
lotion it's 2.5 million it would be a
mess correct but anyway we're not making
a million dollars okay
secondly she wants mouth has never heard
him in a contest judges don't care Shawn
picks a what he wants he knows I always
tell them that no problem I will do mr.
third time in all the years I've been
involved I've done this in the other two
times again we have problems with
athletes confronting judges aggressively
I will destruct call the tianni was
doing this on computer to set up the
program give down breakdown sheet to
everybody
[Applause]
once I left nine Yin didn't do that
[Music]
here's the thing
Shan made things the wieder company
tried to do a webcast and Shawn said
something like you got you know 100
thousand people watching it at $10 a
piece that's a million dollars where's
our money it wasn't that money and Vince
Scalisi who is the editor of Muscle &
Fitness at the time that was doing I
said there's Vince right there Vince how
many people did and Vince told him they
did it for two years they lost money two
years you're in the production business
think about doing a webcast back then 20
years ago with three four cameras and
everything else your production cost has
run forty fifty thousand dollars they
were barely breaking even they you only
stopped doing something when you're
losing money you don't stop doing it if
you're making money it wasn't making
money the webcast and it was being run
by the wieder company not me
why would they want it to continue why
wouldn't they want it to continue they
were losing money no no the athletes
they thought they were making money and
we were pocketing it Sean makes up
things sean has the you know the world
according to Sean okay I drove him at a
sport I could I Drive him out of the
sport in 2001 he's made these things I
he can go yak his mouth all he wants you
know they may come a day where I say you
know Sean if you write it or you say it
it's called libel slander defamation of
character maybe I'll sue you because
then you're gonna have to prove it in
2001 when he supposedly said I drove
matters points 36 years old he was
coming to the end of his time okay
other guys were going and they were all
annoyed because they looked at Ronnie
Coleman it's like their little brother
and all of a sudden little brother got
bigger than everybody and was winning
and was wiping the floor with everyone
and they were wondering why they were
not winning or whatever and they didn't
like him winning I don't know what it
was but I didn't drive him out of the
sport you know
he failed that drug test I didn't give
the urine sample
I didn't collect the urine sample Bob
dr. Bob Goldman did back then I didn't
take it from the cup and put it into the
two vial Shawn de Shawn filled out the
forms Shawn put on the labels Shawn put
on the caps he gave it to dr. Bob
Goldman he signed the documents Goldman
signed the documents Goldman took the
samples put it in the package goldman
sent it to the lab that he was using not
me this was under goldman back to ben
wieder wanted samples were tested the
lab called goldman said this athlete
failed i didn't know one athlete from
another Goldman called Ben weeder
and Ben wieder said you got to tell him
he failed we don't want to okay so I
called Shawn I found out I remember
calling him that he was guest posing
somewhere I believe in Toronto and I
called him in his hotel room and said
sure now unfortunately you failed the
drug test you got the option of doing
sample B you could be there when they
test it and this and that you know the
normal procedure but you know I didn't
fail the drug test
I was just the messenger but he hated me
for that that's okay that's just
prerogative you know Shawn ray and I are
not you know bosom buddies some of the
guys I'm still friends with some I'm not
which ones are you friends with which
one good friends were Paul to let
because Paul the let's a promoter like
me he runs a WBFF right and we talk all
the time talking promotion strategies
dissonant what did you do this where you
did it I was always good friends with
Kevin you know but you know when we took
pictures you know they don't Kevin no we
don't want you talking to when you all
these things you know you're not allowed
to do the gym manion's insecurities
Jimmy's insecure that way I don't know
why I don't hold no ill will against
Jimmy what was a different style of gym
running you versus you running obviously
he's not anymore
we just took place last two weeks ago
but what's the biggest difference
between you running your says gym
running it well let's take the Olympia
the Olympia I would use 12 judges okay
to make it as fair as possible six
foreign judges six American judges
okay we had a computer program developed
where the computer which select randomly
each round the random judge so no one
knew who the random judge was and then
the computer would eliminate the three
highs and three lows to get to it so in
that method if you wanted a 50/50 shot
to fix the contest you'd have to buy off
nine judges and if you wanted a 100%
shot you'd have to buy off ten what's
gonna buy off ten judges and how you're
gonna keep ten judges quiet it is
impossible and it was the fairest way
and no one knew who the alternate was
but Sean talks about the fact that if
for seven years straight it was the same
judges well here's the thing Jim Mannion
picked the American judges he don't say
nothing against Jim Mannion because he
needs to man you to let him in shows now
Jimmy picked the American judges
I picked the foreign judges okay
there would be a change of the judges
when we had panels of eight and nine
there'd be a change of two or three
judges you don't change the whole time
look at boxing do we almost know some of
the boxing judges names that we see them
all the time right I mean where you
gonna get people that understand the
sport that are confident most X athletes
don't want to judge
why isn't shirring judging now why don't
y'all go to Jimmy and say I want to
judge mr. Olympia he doesn't want to
because if he makes a decision he knows
whoever he doesn't put first only the
guy in first is gonna like him and
everybody else is not and he wants to be
in the media part of this because I
heard he's part of Digital muscle now
they won't talk to him you know when
you're a judge you're stating your
opinion and people are not gonna like
you because you state that opinion
because you're voting on you on a
person's most personal thing their body
and they put in time and effort and you
know the strain of going to the gym two
times a day and and everything you got
to do to win and then somebody rips you
apart saying well you know your back
wasn't as good as the other guy I put
you
down you know there's all the
controversy from the 1981 mr. Olympia
when Franco won the changed me we made
after that there was points so when
people say how did Franco win it look at
the score sheet you know Jimmy was a
judge on that Jimmy had did he had to
dilla first but he gave 20 he but he
gave Franco 20 and Dominick serda was a
judge I think he had Platts first but he
gave Franco 20 so all these guys had a
couple of 20 but Franco had a lot of
twenties because everybody in a sympathy
vote and when you eliminate the highs
and lows on just seven judges back then
wasn't even 87 you know one high and one
low that's how we want did I think he
should have won looking at an observer
and I co-head judge that would Oscar
state no do I know what happened because
back then at the Olympia that was an 81
was in Columbus they would do three
rounds in the afternoon which I could
never understand why if I pay for the
judging I see round one quarter turns I
found two seven compulsories I see round
three two posing why am I gonna pay more
money to see the posing at night made no
sense to me I split it up but when we
came back I remember me and Oscar went
back and we're adding the scores and we
look at each other
Franco's gonna win three rounds
Franklin's gonna win so we come back to
the thing Roger Schwab was a judge
Dominick Winston Robert all these guys
you know they all had their guy who they
thought was gonna win you know this guy
thought Dickerson was gonna win he was
in great shape this guy Roy was gonna
work and he was in great shape well
Frank was gonna win Wow
I said you gave him a 20 in this round
and you gave him a 20 and you gave me a
20 and we had a change to placement
which forced the judges to judge because
now you couldn't give away two or three
20s now 1st 2nd 3rd 4th 5th where I say
in there we're gonna give down the
breakdown sheet the judges didn't want
that because then the athlete would see
I got it yeah who paid the judges by the
way who the contest paid the judges
what do you think about that the fact
that you're paying the judges so well
did the local tea of the judges us to
the guy that cuts the check isn't it
no you sure know the judges the judges
was selected I told you Ben wanted Jimmy
to select the American judges from the
MPC fine and I selected the foreign
judges we try to alternate a couple like
I said we'd alternate a couple here now
you can't change the whole panel every
year there's not enough competent people
in the sport now yeah okay you're a
judge you're assigned to judge Leland by
the design of competent people in the
sport say thank you you don't think
there's enough competent people in the
sport to judge the Olympia level no to
change the judging panel every year no
no no these guys that are judges these
guys that are judges I mean if they
don't if they do something out of
control you're probably not gonna bring
him back next year yeah exactly
yeah but that's also like for the
athlete it's kind of like well then you
know they're afraid of the guy that's
cutting the check though does that kind
of make it uncomfortable for the athlete
let's check they get food allowance
money well what I'm saying is that's
even scarier the fact that they're not
getting paid nothing judges they apply
to be a judge they work their way up to
be a judge people want to be involved in
a sport you started a local level I want
to I want to learn to be a judge okay
you could test judge here you could do
this thing it's like that in any sport I
mean yes
let me ask space the umpire let me ask
you this Phil Heath against a rodent in
your judgment who should have won I
can't say unless I was there I can't go
by pictures and I haven't been to a
contest since the last Olympia I ran so
you you don't you can't say unless if
you go there I know this that you unless
I'm there and sitting in close proximity
to the judges so I see the same view as
them yeah I will not give an opinion
once the last time you wrote a mr.
Olympia the last one I ran in 2003 so
from oh three til today you haven't gone
you know so from everything you've ever
seen all the body builders you've ever
seen who's your top five best physiques
so I know you've battled oh no not in no
particular order no no I won't order
like put it in well in order accounting
everything not just body everything
Arnold has to be fir
whose second I would go with you know
and you got to go by certain years I
would say Ahnold 73 74 which I believe
was his best I was there I saw it
even though 75 he was very good and I
saw oh ma I own the outtakes at one time
so I saw old 110 hours of pumping iron
but I still think 73 74 was his peak 75
in my opinion he came back just to do
the movie and this and that wasn't
gung-ho like before you gotta remember
73 when he competed he had tours his
knee guess posing after the 72 Olympia
in South Africa that's posing for reg
Park need a knee surgery so he came back
with a vengeance but people said he
wouldn't come back and he those two
years he was right on the money Dorian
Yates in 93 as one of these pictures
here who's goes this this one with the
original picture to take was taken by
Kevin Horton where he had the pants
around his ankles that was before he
tore anything you put him at second I
don't know I don't know how to put a
second in the top five Sherman okay okay
Lee Haney Lee Haney at his peak again
what was Lee any weaknesses yet none
right there
I can't go up by two guys if after I
left it's fine I'm saying to up two or
three though but that's plenty of names
there up two or three yeah I guess the
other two would be Ronnie and Sergio
Sergio Oliva right so you're leaving out
a lot of names you take me top five you
got leave somebody out okay so Sergio
for you and then Ronnie at that time
no big idea and who they're competing
against in their era
I'm not taking Sergio from 68 and
putting them next to Coleman of 2001
different ear at different time at that
time Sergio in 1960 nobody would compete
against him he was so good you know he
was he was unbeatable you know Lee Haney
at his peak okay it was more pros than
but Lee Haney was very good and very
complete and very big what was Lee
haney's weakness I mean if he had a
weakness a little bit
it was just posing and he worked on it
you know because we judged posing that
you know Dorian to a weakness was
probably worked on it
by the way another change I wanted to
make to make it better
I wanted to scores given for posing
because the way the rules were written
and I read wrote those original rules
with Oscar State round one when they
were doing quarter turns you're judging
the same thing but a different form so
when you're doing the quarter turns
proportion symmetry and balance comes
more into play than muscularity when
you're doing the seven compulsories
muscularity comes more into play because
you're flexing in round three the way it
was written and they don't go by it
anymore anyway the athlete the first two
rounds the judge is saying to the
athlete this is the way I want to see
you round three the athlete is
presenting their body to the judge the
way they want to choreograph to music
and you only judge what you see so for
example Muhammad McHale we will take him
because we're talking camels he was very
good at three quarterback shots but
straight on back he was no good in his
posing routine do no straight on backs
he just did three court he showed his
body to his best advantage you can hide
your weaknesses what I wanted as
routines became more entertaining as I
was pushing for that you take like Vince
Taylor my time Vince Taylor was really
getting into the posing doing the robot
and doing the Macarena man and all that
I saw stuff that brought the house down
he was around 40 so his physique
couldn't stand next to the other guys
but he was definitely the most
entertaining so I wanted the judges to
give two scores one for the
entertainment value of the routine so on
the entertainment value yeah Vince would
have gotten the first and it would have
forced the athletes to do better
routines because that's what you're
selling to the audience why am I gonna
buy a ticket to the show if I'm gonna
see the guy come out there and hit four
poses and then walk to each side of
stage and go like this and hit the same
four and walk to the other side and do
the same thing no I mean I was the one
that came in with the first night of
Champions
you pose to your own music I couldn't
understand that when a guy gets posed he
posed to his own music but when they
went in a contest back then they would
either play Exodus over and over again
from that old movie from the 1960s or in
Columbus they had the organ player
playing something as the guy was posing
and I'm saying first night of champions
round three that we're doing at night
you're posing to your own music because
I was good friends with Ed corny and Ed
was posing to my went whenever he gets
posed even if he wasn't in tip-top shape
he'd bring the house down he was known
as the greatest poet yes and so when
Eddie was going to do that first night
of champions you know as I said you're
pulling humor they couldn't believe it
they said really we could post or yeah
let's do it we're gonna put on a show
crowd loved it within two years every
amateur show in America that kid was
coming with his own music to pose we
changed all it's gotta be entertaining
why do you why did we watch the boxing
match okay last week why don't we watch
full show coming in the way they came in
with no show - hold this hold that it's
a show it's entertaining it has that
today bodybuilding yeah no not at all no
okay so let me ask you this recent to
transition with Jake wood and you got
you got right now you know the
personalities there Jim Mannion okay you
got em he's old school you know Jimmy's
old school Jimmy Jimmy would always say
to me why you spending so much money on
staging I said because I got to give the
people a show he'd go to me how about
David Parker David pecker had the option
of really doing something special and
taken the thing more mainstream with his
mainstream publications and he didn't do
it
and you know they didn't they didn't
know how to make things work I left
everything at Mandalay Bay okay 6,500
people the next year I left right they
didn't reimburse me for the I had the
deposit down for the next two years they
didn't pay me back for the deposit on
okay I gotta screw them if I wanted to
because it was in my name I could have
left them hanging but I didn't they did
it they didn't know how to treat the
people right you know and I don't know
what happened it went downhill you know
they they had a lot less people first
year I wasn't there and then they went
to Mandalay Bay because this was told to
me by Mandalay Bay people that they went
in and they wanted Mandalay Bay to be a
sponsor of the event and put up big
money and give him this a net and they
said we don't do that we got a line of
people for this thing and they went down
the strip to find other people to run
the show and then they came back to
Mandalay Bay two three hours later they
already had to rent it to someone else
I had a great deal with Mandalay Bay I
was friends with everyone there they
took care of me
you know last you know the last year I
ran I had 512 booths at the expo okay
they don't have nowheres near that now I
mean as for Jake wood I mean I don't
know Jake wood I mean I know obviously
he's got a lot of money because
according to the New York Post he paid
seventy million dollars for the Olympia
and the magazine's according to the
Keith Kelly at the New York Post they
had a whole article about it
you know and so he's got lots of you
know he's an aeronautical engineer so
he's a very smart fellow you know I've
heard that he sold his company according
it's writing for lots of money I heard
that he develop a rivet for commercial
jets so he's a smart guy okay
aeronautical engineer I understand
engineering smart guy that Solomon dance
what Dan promote before last year's
Olympia nothing okay Dan Solomon's a
nice guy I met him briefly before I left
nice fellow
nobody says a bad word about him nice
guy you know but does he have that drive
does he have that energy does he have
that foresight does you have that
creativity what you have to be to be a
promoter you know what is the stage
going to be what is this going to be how
you going to get the people in it you
know I look at the other
thing too in a certain way I feel sorry
for Robin Chang because didn't give him
things to work with the marketing okay
meaning meaning athletes I mean I was
lucky I was in the right place at the
right time and I had a lot of marketable
athletes okay and no knock on these guys
but nobody's breaking down doors to see
Brandon Currie or Phil Heath or whatever
they can say what they want about
attendance be you hear all these stories
about copying this and copy that and
again if the Olympia is making that much
money while you're selling it okay if
the Olympians making that much money why
did they fire Robin Cheng okay Robins
doing the work okay I know what it takes
to run that contest okay he's working on
that show all year did it for like 14
years okay
and they just fire you know why you know
he can only do with what he has okay if
you don't have marketable athletes then
you got to go you know I was lucky to
position I was in I would see athletes
and you know okay you know that guy if
he wins the German championships when I
first saw Gunther you know we're gonna
get him got to get him to California and
Nissa neck
he's marketable you know with me Lowe's
and Nasser they were from the former
Yugoslavia and when everything split up
that form you was it didn't exist no
more you know but these were good
bodybuilders that were marketable I
remember when I brought Nasser and you
know when Vince McMahon took a lot of
the marketable guys away in 91 and I
brought all these other guys from York
that nobody had ever seen wanna be in
dorian yates 1991 and dorian Nasser
that's when I've got pastel Ben Faro Ben
Aziza Monza all these new guy
every sample where did you find this guy
all these guys were in Europe they won
there and the fact that the other guys
were gone it was the opportunity okay
I'll give you an invite to Night of
Champions where I'll pay you away
because maybe they couldn't they didn't
have the money to come to me they wanted
to but I didn't have the money so it
opened the door and I would travel
around a lot and go to local contests
all around the world to always look for
other guys I also looked and you know
loopholes like take Charles clammer
Charles Clement was four or five time
naba Universe winner tremendous
bodybuilder late 80s there was always
the good thing in England who is better
in the late eighties Clairmont door
Yeats Clermont won everything and he
didn't want to compete no more there was
nothing else because they wouldn't let
him in the IFBB and I said Ben this is
crazy this is the best athlete naba he's
retiring he's only 28 years old and he's
a good-looking guy
beautiful symmetrical physique
marketable well you know he has to go
through the British Federation I said
you're gonna tell me he's got to go into
mr. London to qualify for the British
Championships and then go into pretty
championships and you know Duty if he
goes into mr. London who's gonna compete
who's gonna hurt who if he goes into mr.
London if he goes into mr. London nobody
else competes you know what rules rules
rules which annoys me these rules
sometimes so I got to be friends with
Clermont because I was just looking at
pictures of them saying we need this guy
look at him another great body built all
I wanted to do it put great body
builders on stage entertain the audience
so I got to know him I said you know
they want you to go to the British thing
you know this Annette he goes you know
I'm under a Barbados passport oh really
I said according to IFBB rules you
represent the country of the which
passport you're under and the head of
that Federation can recommend you for
pro status would out of a win in a
context I take a nobody and recommend
them for pro status so I got in touch
with the head of the Barbados Federation
I said you know Charlie Clermont is
Annette and he goes to me wait
send you a letter of recommendation I
just want one thing you know when you do
the scoresheet put down Charles Clermont
Barbados not Charles Clermont England I
said done so you get to pro chord the
head of English Federation at the time
Julian finds me friend of mine
well he's pissed been spit I said let me
redo the rules Ben Papa Papa here's the
letter can't say nothing I said no I and
when your brother sees him he'll be out
in California taking us fly him out to
California take a picture put him in the
magazine because he's marketable and it
sells tickets and it sells magazines
which is what happened you know
sometimes you know the rules if you're
gonna bend the rules you gotta bend it
for the betterment of the Federation not
for an individual you know promoter
money or this or that you know what the
oldies guys don't know as I built that
European Tour over the years eleven
times to promote a flop
I couldn't pay his bills I paid the
prize money and of course Ben wieder
well you pay me my half at a sanction
fee you wouldn't even let me off do it I
said he lost money he didn't care
I had to pay him that half I paid okay
my company
that's why I'm running the Olympia I
gotta sell VIP seats that last Olympia I
saw I had 660 VIP seats sold going in
every seat at $650 you can multiply it
out times how much particular 650 650 at
600 tickets 660 tickets but it gets even
better in that last Olympia in 2003 to
Iran I go back to my room after the
judging now there was a lot of things
going on in that show and my room is the
sweetest packed I would have Dinah
Anderson a former female bodybuilder and
her husband in the other room because
she was a legal secretary and Carlo was
there from Italy because he was the
computer guy and other people and I
can't even get into my room I said
what's going on here they go win it's
sold out and they want tickets and guys
are going to Wayne please please please
I said let me see what I can do the
other guy that was there was Giorgio -
colos the star of ancient aliens George
Jones like my other son I met him in in
Europe when he was 16
you want to be a promoter he did promote
for me for five years and he was up
there too he'd always helped me a
children so I called a box office I go
Kim
I'm looking at the schematic can we fit
in to all the roles of folding chairs in
the back on both sides of the center
section she goes Wayne for you I'll cuz
I picked the girls from the box office
out every time I go on a production
meeting I go on a Friday because they'd
never go back to work I'd take them to
the Mexican restaurant we don't get
drunk they call the fire marshal they
call the head of Mandalay Bay and
everything they go Wayne they'll do it
till it's two rows of 16 on each side
that's 64 seats but the fire marshal
wants us two sons to be able to go
backstage and some of the executives
want their son I said have all the sons
come they'll they hang with me backstage
the whole show they go done so I go to
the people in my room I said they're
printing up tickets now I said Georgia
go down to Kim and get the tickets
you're gonna get the finals you'll get
the banquet and you get the seminar
tomorrow I'm not going to charge you 650
I got a charge of 600 and it's got to be
cash you got time when Giorgio comes
back you're getting a line you give me
the cash sold in no time they wanted to
see a show they know who's gonna be a
good show they know it's gonna be
entertaining we ran that show we had a
script on the night show both that in
Night of Champions minute by minute we
knew exactly everything we'd collect the
music on the Wednesday night at the
meeting we'd have we knew the order of
the competitors so let's say a guy out
of music 8 9 minutes hey you got eight
nine minutes on all I'm only gonna do
the first two minutes and 45 seconds
okay we did it put it on there put it on
a mini disc cleaned it so the acoustic
Li was perfect
on a mini disc in that order we just
pushed the number song number one
Porsche it comes right out so if he
wanted it as he enters of stage or in
position we had it we had all their
everybody's on headphones the sound guy
the lighting guys Charlie calling a show
me backstage all the backstage people it
was long like a regular Broadway play
the stage hands would say to us
we can't believe you do so much here for
a one night show what kind of money
you're making at this time at the
Olympia
the Olympian and you know I'd fight with
the weeders on the elliptical they
always wanted more and more that last
Olympia our expenses were 1.65 million
and we gave away four hundred thousand
four hundred ten thousand and the
cadillac escalade and we took in about
two point two six two point almost two
point three okay so we made close to 600
thousand okay on the show but when you
look at it percentage-wise
we're making like twenty seven percent
of the gross a normal business if you do
ten percent you're doing great
normal is eight percent we were doing
twenty seven twenty eight percent is
that what the athletes were upset about
the fact that they could got a more cash
out of it or no I was raising the prize
money every year you know you don't know
what the attendance is going to be I
raised it every year and then every year
they're adding in you got to remember
that was just the men I had women's
bodybuilding yeah I had fitness
bodybuilding and by 2003 I had figured
one of the problems that they have now
is you've got so many divisions last
year they gave away about 1.45 million
in total prize money okay eight hundred
thousand to the men total prize money
you got Dwayne Johnson with athletic on
saying on the bodybuilding part they're
hinting that they're going to top the
Olympia well you're gonna have to go
more than one point five then because
the Olympia if they do all the things
that go add wellness in another division
they're gonna go over one point five
it's not just mr. anymore you know it's
it's all over the place I look at what
they do want to let it con and you got
to remember the Olympia the focal point
was mr. Olympia bodybuilding everything
was bodybuilding which thought on
Wednesday night they laughed a me saying
what are you going to on Wednesday night
muscle movie night I said yeah it's
gonna get the fans in earlier get them
in the mood it's for free the hotels
giving me the room for free I got to pay
a hundred and fifty dollars for the
thing to project it on the screen but
with every movie each year I'm gonna
bring in somebody so of course the first
year is pumping iron everybody's seen it
but I brought in George Butler and they
could ask Georgie any question about the
film and this Annette 450 plus people
showed up now of course every room night
I get credit for free rooms and I get a
kickback okay after you pass so much
they make you all these deals and
everything and the more I got that's why
I got the expo hall for free I got a
hundred and sixty eight thousand square
feet at Bayside B for free because I
booked so many rooms I had so many room
nights in the place okay the guys liked
me so much the Union guys they'd say to
me
Wayne nobody's in here when do you want
to come in and set up and I go well set
up days at back then with twenty five
thousand a day plus you where you going
with this was I'm just saying because
where I'm going is where's the money is
why we made so much profit because I
made deals with people right so let me
ask you a question in oh three your last
one you did how much the first place
make
[Music]
so I thought he had to make a hundred or
125 plus the car so so 100 grand plus
the car deescalate yeah so first place
is winning somewhere around two hundred
thousand dollars 150 cars 50 grand let's
just say it was fully loaded extended
Cadillac Escalade that's about 60 grand
yeah so I'm one of my between 160 to 180
depending on if it's 120 or $100,000
yeah from oh three two now $400,000
growth okay once they say 120 it's three
xed okay I mean it's it's gone
relatively high so let me let me ask you
this
do you know you go into a Dana got heat
because Dana wasn't paying two fighters
well okay that's what Dana White was
getting keyed for you got in in mob
world Paul Castellano got heat because
he wasn't sharing the profits that the
family was making so he eventually took
him out kind of like they took you out
okay eventually put me out I quit I'm a
quiet you'll I get it but also at the
same time you don't have a lot of allies
with these competitors because when I
look from the outside when you see
you're like the ideal promoter to do
this kind of stuff but let me let me get
to my question here's my question for
you this one I'm going with this but
eventually what what a Mayweather did
Mayweather said I want to take outs on
how many pay-per-views we sell so what
about if we change a portion of the
payout because you know a lot of the
camp there's two camps there's one camp
that's saying this last mr. Olympia
biggest tickets sell ever more than em
yeah it's the greatest I've ever had if
you look at the pictures it was so that
you couldn't fit a single person in here
it was unbelievable right now you
weren't there so if you don't want to
irritate the upper deck was was not even
opened okay I'm just telling you what
this hey so now watch the other side so
what what if you know you got an
opportunity to say guys first place is
400 grand okay what else and here's the
thing if you help us sell XYZ amount of
tickets on top of that I'm gonna put
another three hundred thousand dollars
into the pool with the same mathematical
formula so maybe tops gonna get sixty
thousand that's gonna if you sell this
many tickets
another six hundred thousand if you get
much another $900,000 now I'm going to
place with this so the athletes are not
going to be saying well you want there's
one thing you're not taking it was down
two thirds of the profits went to the
weavers at that time yeah
how about today I don't know what they
deal is now right so at that time wait
out of the $600,000 two thirds went to
the reader so four hundred thousand
dollars one today I'm 200 was kept by
you is this public everybody knows this
I never hid it okay so so Wow two-thirds
went to Wieters no [ __ ] okay see that's
when you insure intoxicant Olympia or
alive that's why we created the Olympia
weekend because if Miss Olympia was on
its own it was gonna die for someone
giving you compliment I think you're
crazy promoter what I'm trying to tell
you a ridiculous promoter yeah I mean
yours you can't even hold yourself with
all these stories in the way you're
telling details you're telling the deal
of I got crazy mind I know but you're
that's a part of a being a promoter so
to know that you can't teach this you
can't teach somebody how to do this you
either gather you don't have it so you
could have gone been a politician being
a campaign manager for somebody you
would have done a great job just to go
on in that route so it's okay so what do
you think right now with the future of
mr. Olympia do you think do you think
athletic con is bringing because you
know sometimes the political answer is
oh we always know athletic on what's
gonna happen we support them at the rock
this is great this is just gonna bring
more attention to Mastro Olympia this is
a very good thing behind closed doors
we've been talking to each other this is
exactly what we want him to do then
there's another camp that says hell no
dirac and Danny they want to take the
entire attention away and they want to
kind of get get the athletic on to
become bigger
what do you know with some of the
conversations you're at okay let's look
at this before the sale you really think
that Robin Chang wanted to help the
Olympia David pecker fired him I don't
think Robin now I didn't speak to him
I'm just looking from the outside what
do you really want to help David pecker
I don't think so okay so now that it's
gone
to Jake wood
I don't know what that dynamic is I mean
if let it con if you read what they're
trying to do there is beyond anything
and guy remember
it's letter con it's not a bodybuilding
show it's uh it's a fitness thing body
buildings one part of sure and you know
the fact I mean what are they paying
and even though Dwayne Johnson has
connections in the Hollywood industry
where he says he's gonna have top music
acts and stop comedians at that party
Saturday I read about a letter Khanna
said wow I want to buy a ticket and go
how do you fight that how do I compete
against ya
I said I wanna buy a ticket and go it
sounds great they gonna have meditation
yoga they're gonna have everything there
now his budget I would estimate he's
using all of the World Congress Center
to eight hundred and fifty thousand
square feet and he's using the outside
area I've read to do the the party that
Saturday night thing that kind of have a
ton of security there because if you're
gonna have alcohol everybody partying
it's like a club or whatever you know
how that goes
but it's but it's gotta be somewhere
between seven and ten million dollars
okay you know that's heavy duty we know
where the Olympia budget is the on
budgets probably between a half to four
say in there with everything this is
this is big-time is this a threat though
well I mean it depends on if the
promoters are working together I mean I
always had a relationship with Jim Laura
and I would never push the Olympia until
the Arnold was over and vice-versa
respect yeah respect right and we were
friends respect yeah but you know you're
on your tennis team Arnold you you you
guys have no illusions you know they
would hire me to coordinate the
bodybuilding part of their event so we
were all together I don't see any big
things from athletic on yet so maybe
they got the same respect there you know
and we don't see anything big from the
Olympia yet you know of course the sale
was going on I don't know what Jake
Woods objective is if he just doesn't
care about making money he could make
the most spectacular event ever okay
I don't know you know if you
wants to make money well he's got to
make a lot of changes you know hey Jake
you want to make money give me a call
I'll give you advice how to make money
on that event you know but you know was
that a plug let me ask you let me ask
you a question let me ask you a question
are you indirectly wanting to go back
and promote mr. Olympia you know would
you like to know if it sounds like it no
no I like promoting if Jake called you
and says listen III want you to come and
consider promoting mr. Olympia would you
do it I talked to him okay so you would
want to do it
if the money was right it was like
there's an itch there he feels like I
just like I you know I like to create I
liked him it's like I give you an
example when I was a little boy you know
I used to like my electric trains but I
do all these elaborate setups but after
it was built and they went around a
circle once I was bored hmm what I found
with contests I come up with a concept
we're gonna do this the edge they're
gonna be this is gonna be that and you
build to that day and once you get to
that day it's over yeah you relax you
didn't but then you start all over again
it's like a movie I know why people like
movies I couldn't my brain could have
went for that you do a movie you put all
this effort and you do this to use it
and then you move on to another project
I was thinking of leaving bodybuilding I
was getting bored numerous times it was
becoming the same thing over and I was
going to quit after 98 a couple of
things when I was getting bored and two
that's when I got the prostate cancer
and who knows what was going on and then
the opportunity came to move it to Vegas
Vegas excited me okay Vegas fun there's
an app and the possibility of staying in
the same location and building it out
but by 2003 when I went after the
contest was over and the banquet goes on
but I never made it to the banquet were
taken down things we got to make sure
everything gets back then the truck and
everything is the right way and my
second wife Palvin Ari was there with my
son
they held a little bit of food for me
and I remember saying I heard that night
I said uh I don't think I'm gonna do
this anymore
I mean you should have made a lot of
money too with so many people and I auto
shows up for you
oh no came to that 2003 Olympia because
I donated for his campaign and wanted a
few people from bodybuilding that did
and when I went to his last fundraiser
that was run by goals and world's gym
when he walked through the crowd you saw
me there it says rain you came I said no
no I support you
he says I come to Olympia for you and
this was the Friday week before eight
days before I said no no you're gonna
win on Tuesday it's gonna be King you
have my word I come for you I don't say
a word to nobody because you know you
put that out there and then you don't
show up it's a letdown so I don't think
Charlie don't even know nobody knows oh
no no not to do that and we finished our
judging we would do the judging at 12
noon on a Saturday and a 2 o'clock I get
a call and they go Wayne to Millie I go
yeah this is uh chief so-and-so from the
California Highway Patrol we need you to
put us in touch with the Nevada State
Police the Las Vegas police and the
Mandalay Bay security I said any reason
they go yes the governor-elect is coming
this is when you know it's legit yeah
and he goes when he lands we're gonna
close down Las Vegas Boulevard so he
doesn't get caught in traffic I said
well when is he landing they go about
seven o'clock I said you're gonna close
down Las Vegas Boulevard seven o'clock
on a Saturday night singles yes we are
and you know that's when I called
Mandalay Bay Network little leak out not
much but he came and the fans didn't
know was a reaction pandemonium that's
your last one ever yeah my last Olimpia
we must finished it with that yeah and
you didn't come back no did you get
fired or you didn't come back
me and Ben were fighting so much every
day Decker wanted to take over he said
you know if I take over the Olympia you
know you're gonna run it in this and I
said I can't take it with Ben no more
and then he made a deal with Ben you
know and Ben said you know Wayne and
pecker and we didn't Lauren what we're
trying to undermine me and this and that
and
Arnold told pecker don't sign wood then
you'll regret it Arnold toward pecker
don't sign wood Ben you'll regret it
mm-hmm Ben and Joe Bennett Bennett and
Arnold didn't get along but but honor
God along with Joe but not bad not bad
what's best personality like Ben was a
businessman Joe was more the bodybuilder
guy so been fired you then said to me I
don't think we can exist anymore I said
you're right I said I can't take this
anymore I'm living in stress everyday
with my medical condition
I don't need stress I don't need this no
more you think you can do it better go
ahead watch what happens and I said
that's it what's the last Olympia that
was the biggest Olympia it's oh three
the last biggest one I can't tell what
other Olympians did since I left I
wasn't there I don't know what the box
office receipts are I can't comment on
something I will add on the inside for
but you know you don't have marketable
guys either they're not bringing in
marketable how do you know though you
know you don't know you're not there to
see it you said I don't want a judge
because I'm not there so well I'm saying
they're not marketable they're not
selling the tickets there's no
excitement is there excitement about
bran and curry no knock on the guy maybe
a nice fellow I don't know but I don't
see an excitement there yeah marketable
is a different story your marketability
is is it completely different I get it
I told you get it you gotta have a
personality Arnold was marketable even
my dad also was 16 you know wasn't
winning but he was still a marketable
personality you had some of these guys
that were marketable personalities so so
okay and then you had and then you had
at the time you had magazines with Joe
knowing how to create personalities and
create marketable guys yeah okay
now with the internet magazines dead
it's almost self-promotion and it's all
over the place and you may have so many
followers on Instagram or whatever but
it doesn't translate into tickets you
got to do that last question for you
yeah one of Joe weeders dreams was to
for Mistral and Peter goal in two
Olympics I know they did the Pan Am
stuff is this ever gonna happen or is
Ben's dream Rafael's trying but you got
the drug
think problem it's difficult you know
the IFBB Raphael's part of the IFBB
cookbook Jimmy and Raphael your boss or
no huh Israel fill your boss or
technically that's kind of why it's
right you know when he called me to ask
me to come you gotta remember I was his
boss yeah I know that but but I mean
it's you're almost like doing each other
for you it's not even out yeah yeah I
mean I call up Raffy it's different you
know
but there's respect there's a respect
for you I told him I said Raphael you
know me I said every time I would flip
out on Ben Ben would call you up saying
I can't take her with him no more I said
but you want me to be aggressive and
energetic because if I'm not then I'm
useless if I don't have this energy then
I'm no good for anything okay
so if I don't have a passion for what
I'm doing then why do it
get somebody else you just want a yes
man now I'm not the guy for you I'm not
the guy for you
you know you gotta be aggressive yeah
I'm you know I'm not making no money
running a body but I make my money doing
other things but you know it's kind of
fun trying to teach young younger guys
or guys that never promoted before to do
some catch on and do it and they follow
you some don't
it's kind of nice on these yeah these
shows aren't big 35 people in this show
22 people in this show whatever and but
when he athlete comes up to you and say
you know we like the organization you're
putting together you know nothing's
going on here you know her deal like so
much music America yeah yeah IFBB
physique America calm that's what you're
doing yeah and you know so when an
athlete comes to you and says you know
thank you it was a nice show we've taken
all the membership money okay and we're
sending athletes every show to different
international events you know it does
that you're not doing it for money this
is a passion play yeah you still have
the passion for this game yeah to a
point yeah - yes or no yes so not -
what's there - points look the point is
money you got to make some money if
these guys call you yeah if the other
guys want me to you know I'm not gonna
you know four years of running the
Olympia and teaching myself learning on
my own how to run big events I'm not
gonna give it away - Jake would this
equation boys Salomon crazy I mean not a
crazy question
what what is a quality of a great
promoter what makes a great promoter
from your eyes you're a great promoter
what makes somebody a great promoter you
have to have the passion for it one okay
you have to be creative you got to think
like a fan what entertains you I'm still
a fan I would always say to people you
know when the show started and I'm
sitting there with the judges I got the
best seat in the house and the show goes
and I'm creating this whatever this
entertainment that I put in my head you
got to entertain people
anything Pro is entertaining this show
is no good if you don't entertain people
why do people watch it do you got to be
entertaining if everybody comes out and
does the same thing it's boring nobody
ever knew what I was going to do at
Night of Champions so so a sense of
surprise a sense of unknown yeah you
think that's quality of a promoter part
of it what else so so far I have passion
creative entertain a sense of the
unknown well you got work all the time
you got to work all the time I would I
say to promoters
you're promoting a show every day you
got to get something accomplished i when
I would run the Olympia I would give
myself goals I would play games with
myself I was like okay this week I'm
gonna raise $20,000 in vendors and
sponsors and let's say I sign a company
for 25,000 on Tuesday I don't take the
rest of the week off hey maybe I could
get to 50,000 this week I'm gonna push
even harder the last three days I was
always competing against myself to make
it better that's why in 2003 you know
let's face it in 2003 you had well let's
go back a couple years Jay was winning
in 2001 after the judging and Ronnie
came back and beat him and Jay got mad
he thought i fixed the show against him
I said to him one time I'm a promoter I
do this to make money who's gonna sell
me more tickets a big white blond guy or
the big black guy come on Don King told
me one time Don King came to when we did
women's bodybuilding the women's pumping
iron and he saw I was promoting that
thing he goes remember one thing boy
white means green I know what he meant
he goes you know how much money I made
off Gerry Cooney fightin combs
we all knew homes we've got to kill them
his boxing kills with soap but they
built up Cooney you get the thing the
audience is 95% white right you don't
have white guys in the show dissing at
Jay Cutler didn't win in 2001 he was
upset so he didn't compete in 2002 let's
go back stay focused hang on because I
want to get this out of you because
because I'm trying to get this out of
you because I think it's brilliant what
you're saying
number one is passion yeah you got to be
passion about what you're promoting
number two is being creative you can't
think like everybody else and be
illogical or conventional number three
is entertained you got to entertain for
you this sense of the unknown some kind
of a surprise yeah number five you're
working all the time yeah number six you
said competitiveness I'm going to
compete against yourself to push
yourself to succeed okay how about the
next one do you think there's a part of
it of you choosing the right person to
be face of the sport or all of that or
no you don't think that playing it pick
the faces meaning Conor is go I get that
but Conor is great for MMA right
Mayweather was good for boxing yeah yeah
well the thing is I would pick the guys
who I put on the poster who would sell
me tickets
I'd go sign up a guy so maybe that's
picked the market oh god yeah I'm with
them I just at Night of Champions and
Night of Champions we would try to get
the Year befores overall USA and
Nationals winner that would be their pro
debut I would always say whether wins
newest a internationals your turn pro I
puff are you in tonight of Champions
you're in that show so the fans knew
they were gonna see the young up
upcoming guys here I would always bring
back three four five favorites people
that they knew you know that they liked
that the New York audience like the host
stars and they like I always bring in
and unknown from Europe okay so I would
fly in because I would have sometimes 45
50 guys in Night of Champions
I would pay full expenses for like 16 to
18 and then guys from that lived in the
area that could drive I would pay their
hotel yeah I said you driving off Friday
I don't want you going back and forth
you stay in a hotel I'll pay pourcel
expenses and in guys that I didn't know
that wanted to come and pay their way
and make their mark do this during the
judging the judges would judge one to
fifteen everyone else is 16
at the beginning of the show at night
the ones that didn't make the top 15
they'd come out depending on how many
one or two at a time and do you know 15
20 seconds of posing and this and that
and then they were done the top 15 did
their full posing routine for the
audience we would start that show at
8:05 we'd end at 10:15 on the button all
timed out you want the people leaving
wanting more okay that's another one
okay so what else so here's again
passion creative entertain sense of
unknown work your ass off compete
against your prior best pick the right
person to be the face like a marketable
guy think like a fan which you just said
right now is people leaving wanting more
give me one more when we get one more
out of you just having energy to do it
okay miles I would walk in Mandalay Bay
going from my room down the elevators to
where the convention was where the
theater wore greatest was where that was
you got to do what you got to do give me
one of these but we're not even done and
I was freaking sick I got data that was
sick
anybody well no matter what business
you're in you just heard from one of the
best promoters in the stores sport of
bodybuilding which was never a
marketable product years ago to go from
doing the most shows we can't learn
something from here the the deep
promoter speed round I'm gonna give you
a name you give me one word okay let's
see what you can do here I'll give you a
name you give me one word germanium
friend form a friend friend or former
friend well you don't want to talk to me
I gave you because you're my friend but
that's two words so I get what it's okay
now you're good with that I know an
enemy I don't hate go on you know I
don't know why Arnold greatest
bodybuilder greatest greatest ever Lee
Priest under under appreciated Wow Sean
ray
one word for Sean ray mmm
unhappy you know he you know not one
word but you know they were years you
know I like Dorian Dorian is a great guy
91 he pushed Haney 92 we won it was like
227 pounds 90 Toria he was tremendous
that picture but when he started tearing
things I didn't agree with the judges
that he should have won you know just my
opinion
I thought those years could flex of one
could Shawn have one quit Kevin have one
yeah I I could have seen that you know
but I wasn't a judge I don't tell the
judges who to vote for I tell them how
the judge meaning apply the rules but I
don't tell them who the judge who to
vote for yeah Sean I mean when you look
at Sean's physique you know weaknesses
yeah well what Sean's weakness it wasn't
quite as tall as the other fellows
probably could have wore his trunks a
little bit higher so we didn't see him
as long wasted you know you created an
optical illusion you look at the guys
back on of time how much bigger the
trunks were now they're basically
wearing bikinis if your trunks are
higher you don't seem as long wasted
where they say always sky-high lats well
if his trunks were you know an inch
below his belly button true instead of
six inches it's all an optical illusion
and that's why I think Sean was unhappy
you know people would say to me why do
you let him speak why do you let him
knock you why do you let him say things
at the press conference and I would
always say Sean may say a hundred things
99 maybe idiotic or annoy me but he may
say one thing that's good and that's
what you have to do when you're in
charge and that's something that nobody
sees and let's look at another thing no
matter who the president is half the
people hate them okay if you're in
charge and you let people have freedom
to speak and speak their minds and write
anything they want and say anything they
want publicly privately you're gonna get
knocked once you come out from the crowd
and you're up here your target mm-hmm if
you don't want to be a target
then don't do it you know I understood
that from the beginning and it was like
I understood that other phrase publicity
good or bad as long as they spell my
name right long you put about the things
you mention the contest you mentioned
mr. pincher that what is my job not to
Pat myself on the back my job is to
promote good contests I I continue to
promote good contests and make money I
continue to promote contests and build a
sport if I had lost money and gone away
what would happen to pro bodybuilding if
I didn't take that risk and use my own
money yeah people criticize you I'm sure
all the time yeah do you care no you
enjoy what you're doing actually I
learned a lot I gotta tell you I learn a
lot because the way I look at it is Mike
and my heavy duty critics who are
competitors there be the best
consultants I'll have because they
identify my weakness more than my peers
ever will and that's how you get better
it's the best consultants cheapest
consultants because you don't pay for it
they just criticize you yeah it's like
you know I would get criticized with
those things guys that were into women
bodybuilding why don't the women get
paid as much as the man they don't bring
in the money I would say to people
during those press conferences you want
to run Miss Olympia you think it's so
profitable I'll talk to Ben we'll give
it to you with no sanction fee you could
run it see what happens I put it
together to keep it the men of
supporting the women that's why we did
it that's the longest two words I've
seen in my life okay it's okay that's
okay
maybe a David Becker David Becker
there's so much goes on with David
pecker bodybuilding and non bodybuilding
[Laughter]
Trump Trump is my aunt's a truck guy
fair enough Joe Weider
innovator Ben wheeler administrator
Ronnie Coleman great champion champion
flex wheeler aesthetics Oh somebody mass
Phil Heath I don't know him that well
hopefully for post 203 a fair enough
Mike Matarazzo great guy great guy they
hurt me when he left us some of these
guys when they've gone the night nasa
died Kevin Paul and my cell phone on the
phone till 3:00 in the morning I mean
you know you got to remember on those
tours we'd live together like a rock
band you know and you know Nasser Paul
flex Chris
Melo's you know there was a group of
guys that would go at we'd go every year
Vince Ronnie a lot of times Dorian do
half of it Shawn never went I don't
think the guys could be rough on each
other at times okay I don't think he had
the temperament to handle that but we
were close we get in fights where we
wanted to beat each other up and we'd
other times we defend each other and we
talk about it and we laugh about it I
mean and you know NASA was only one 4748
it hurt ma terrazzo you know moderato
found happiness he had a young daughter
you know and you know some people get
bad side effects from the supplements
and sometimes like some people get lung
cancer from smoking and some don't and
you know Mikey like his heart couldn't
handle it you know and he was on a list
for a transplant and it didn't come in
time you know and that hurts you know
because
it was more than just with some of these
guys um athlete him official he became
friends in a certain way I knew Mikey's
mom and dad that his dad was in a
wheelchair whenever you compete tonight
a champion I said your dad never has to
get a ticket you get to bed and he comes
right down in front and this and that
you know Mikey appreciated that like hey
I was happy that dad was there poor guy
was in what you know I look at myself
I'm 70 years old
I've been fighting prostate cancer for
22 years they told me in 1998 I had one
two three months to live and Here I am
I'm bouncing around look at me and you
know I think Mikey's dad when he would
come to the shows was in the late 50s
the poor guy was in a wheelchair it's
like you know you look at all the people
you know and then you realize how lucky
you are and you don't complain about
your life you just go on in life and
just be thankful every day I wake up
every day and I say how nothing hurts I
could go to the gym yeah I can't lift
what I used to but I could still do okay
and cancer you're not gonna get me today
because I'm gonna drink my green drink
and have my almond milk and drink liters
of water and do whatever I got to do to
live a good life and to be the way I am
you know a lot of people don't believe
my age because of my energy and you know
when I take the drugs that kill my
testosterone
I mean basically they chemically
castrate me half the year I'm chemically
castrated and you suffer depression I've
learned how to deal with it without
drugs I found that works for me espresso
being Italian you know the caffeine
kicks in a little bit of serotonin and
I'm fine but you know when I'm on the
drugs especially after four months you
wake up with suicidal thoughts but I'm
lucky I know how to deal with it and
then I just get myself down and it's not
sometimes you wake up in the middle of
night the suicidal thoughts are so bad
you got to get up at 3:30 in the morning
cause you can't sleep you know
so you appreciate other things in life
and you deal with it you know and like I
said when we lose some of our guys
Munzer ones are competed in San
Francisco Grand Prix I guess that was 94
I believe off the top of my head
and I saw him when he checked out at a
hotel on the Sunday morning and I get a
call Tuesday early in the morning my
time from one of my guys in Germany
saying he passed away last night I said
I saw him Sunday he flew home he got
home Monday he went to went out he was
drinking beer but everything fell apart
in his system you know and he he died
you know and you know he wanted to be a
champion so much that he would take
drugs to mask things even though he was
told by many doctors stop doing it you
know and sometimes guys can't they want
it so bad you know and the steroids
come on you don't know what we felt like
when we were 17 18 19 years old like you
know we could run through the wall or
indestructible well you know they've
taken steroids artificial testosterone
that's ten times that amount so they
feel yep indestructible and they can't
go you know it's crazy you opened up
with that you're finishing with that it
tells you you know what consumes your
mind the most with the sport you know I
gotta tell you when I almost didn't do
this interview when they reached out to
remember like why why am I gonna sit
down Woodman I don't want to do any more
bodybuilding interviews this it's not a
bodybuilding channel I'm like enough of
these bodybuilding it's my passion I
love their sport I see I grew up with
this think I've made my money because of
bodybuilding because every single time a
guy named Fred gambar II I'm saying his
last name probably wrong at YMCA told me
to increase the weights by 25 pounds and
I went from barely benching the bar to
doing three plates and a quarter on each
side and I was in the Army competing and
I wanted to be a minstrel in pure gada
and I said I don't want to do it but
that that discipline of being a
bodybuilder for that period it it bled
into work it bled into business it bled
into entrepreneurship so I feel like in
a way I want to give back as much as I
can but this is a channel that's for
business and we do a lot of different
interviews but I got to tell you I had a
blast sitting with you hey this the
longest interview we've ever done would
you say yes Marty how long have we been
sitting here first of all you're
long-winded very obvious you can talk
four nights four days but I've had a
problem
at that stage they're in a debate I'll
talk Bernie just telling you I really
enjoyed talking to you thank you I
really sincerely enjoy talking to just
having a conversation with you and I
know we cover a lot of different things
a lot of different topics I know the
bodybuilding community is gonna look at
this and they're gonna do what they're
gonna do and they're gonna say whatever
you say and we didn't even get into the
pumping iron films that we didn't get
into the high Major League Baseball I
hope that I'm not gonna get a chance to
kiss my daughter good night tonight but
I but I'm gonna more important but I
wanted I wanted to have this
conversation with you and I'm glad it
went in the direction it went because I
feel smarter every time I'm sitting down
and I got it from a different
perspective on what you said and I hope
the viewers that are watching this has
walk out a different perspective about
mr. Olympia there's one thing for sure
like you not like you disagree with you
the passions there and there's no way in
the world somebody can teach somebody
how to have that passion that passion is
in your bones and it's very very obvious
and again I appreciate you for coming
out thank for people to get a hold you
what do you want to do what do you want
to direct them to is the physique
American IFBB physique America calm okay
and we're gonna put that link below for
them to get a see that any are you an
Instagram guy or Twitter and you that's
support more than ever I don't post and
you don't really post them well I mean
for anything we'll send a link over yes
and put it to that so if they want to
compete in our shows and like I say you
know like our first show is March 22nd
in Florida to athletes are gonna win a
trip a male and a female this is
fantastic this is gonna stay for a while
stead of giving a date
yeah just keep in mind that these guys
are gonna be going any avail there's
some people gonna go to on classic South
Africa some people win trips to our pro
qualifier in Miami in July you know I'm
not taking a dime I'm putting all the
money back and people think I'm crazy
but you know what you can't take it with
you I would always get on Ben wheeler I
said what are you gonna do with all this
money you can't take it with you and he
would always go to me I'm going to try
him up but you can't you know and you
know I I think my disease my illness I
was always positive but it brought me to
a different level
you know and whenever I get caught up in
the business rat race say I always bring
myself back to the night before my
surgery where the doctors came in saying
Wayne we're gonna open you up and this
and that but we think it's in the lymph
nodes we think he got you know not much
time blah blah blah and I thought in my
head when they left I said when I get
past this because I was always positive
I'm not gonna let relationship problems
business problems financial problems
affect me because those can all be dealt
with another individual this I had to be
blessed to get to hear whatever reason
why I'm still here I don't know you know
the cancer still in me I go for tests
every three months I go for scans and
isn't that once a year I got to do what
I got to do but you know it makes you
look at life different so when things go
bad and you and you're upset about
something I always pull myself back and
say it's okay no big deal it's very
obvious it's very obvious you got that
and I applaud you for it and they're all
the body builders I like them all you
know I like Sean I don't hate Sean you
know like I said it's a great body
builder you know he's got you know
you're gonna hear from him you're gonna
hear from what they're saying from this
one and oh yeah like I I you know hey
they can say what they want you know I
basically some people say when you
created pro bodybuilding cause it really
didn't exist before you came along you
did all these shows and lalala you know
what I think we need to do you know and
it's like yeah I did it I enjoy doing it
I mean my favorite day of the year was
Night of Champions date I was you know
that was my baby - all these are babies
and you know that show the Olympia it
was big you had to deal with so much and
this and that and it was big it was a
satisfying but it was big but Night of
Champions was that morning I could never
sleep the night before
I wouldn't stay at the hotel I'd sleep
home because it was so close and I get
up like at 4:00 in the morning and this
and I couldn't wait to get there and
truck would come at 7:30 and the Union
guys would open the door at 8:00 and
they'd let us unload the truck because
I'd buy to breakfast because they get
paid for it they didn't have to work and
they're eating and then letting us do
the work so he could have better staging
because I had you know 20 guys would
show up that would work it was always so
much fun and in the way just to tell you
this if we go two minutes longer my
guy's not gonna be able to see his girl
tonight okay
he's gotta go see his girl tonight how
old is your girl he's got a lot of them
because he's a tinder expert it's easy
completely easy easy I don't know if
you're from my finger I could tell you
that finally if I show you what I got if
you if you attend their expert like he
is he's always not up well I do with
that but wait I'll come back any time
yeah I mean I'm telling you I'm Jenny I
really enjoyed this conversation there
was a lot of depth and it's preciate you
for coming out and thank you really
Wayne can tell stories I mean if I would
have let him we would have gone for
another 2-3 hours but we all had places
to go to but it was still amazing to
hear the stories and his passion for the
love of bodybuilding and promoting that
one part about the ten things I was able
to get out of him on what makes a great
promoter you see a lot of similarities
between that world they know wide you
know dunking different styles but still
a lot to learn from there but if you
enjoyed this interview and you into the
bodybuilding world and you made it all
the way to the end I'm assuming you love
bodybuilding there's two other ones I
want you to watch one of them is Sean
rate which led to us wanting to do this
so if you've now watched this one click
over you to watch John Ray's interview
if you watch that there's another one I
want you to watch by Dorian Yates which
is absolutely interesting as well click
on either one of them if not subscribe
to the channel please do so thanks for
watching everybody take care bye
you
[Music]